All right, good morning, everyone.
Seeing that the board members are now present, Brooks, will you please call the roll to establish
a quorum?
Good morning.
Member Rodriguez.
Are you?
I see Member Rodriguez.
I'm just making sure she's in.
Are you connected to audio, Brooks?
I should be.
We're not yet hearing you.
Brooks.
Yeah, the mic says it's live here.
And we can hear me in the room.
Okay.
We're seeing you.
Would you like me to call the roll?
President Darling-Hammond, this is the quorum?
This is Judy Saez.
Please do.
Okay.
Thank you.
Member Bonocca.
Here.
Member Darling-Hammond.
President Darling-Hammond.
Here.
Member Bonocca.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you.
Okay.
President Darling-Hammond.
Member Escobedo.
Here.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Member Lewis.
Here.
Member McQuillan.
Member Olken.
Here.
Member Oresco-Gonzalez.
Member Patio-Bronson.
Here.
Good morning.
And member Rodriguez.
Here.
Great.
We have a quorum.
Thank you.
Terrific.
In closed session,
the board took action on Mark S versus state.
And now we are looking for the public comment slide
to go up so that we can discuss the waiver consent items.
Waivers W-1 through W-19.
We'll open the phone line for the public comment queue.
And give it a couple of minutes
to be sure people can catch up with us.
Is there any comment on those items, public comment?
We do have a few people in the queue currently.
I will open the phone line now.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller, ending with the last four digits, five, seven, six,
five, you are live.
Please start your public comment now.
Okay.
Hearing none.
Moving on to the next caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller, ending in the last four digits, five, seven, six,
five, you are live.
Caller, ending in the last.
Okay, I was told we need to hold off on public comment
for just one moment.
I think they're having some technical issues.
I apologize.
Okay.
All right, I think we're gonna just go ahead
and take a five minute break.
Let the technology folks work out the needs there.
If you need a cup of coffee or whatever this morning,
we'll reconvene at about 9.15.
All right.
Welcome back, everyone.
I think our technology issues have been resolved
and we will ask Brooks to call the roll
to reestablish the quorum.
Great, thank you.
And thank you everyone for your patience.
Member Rodriguez.
Here.
Member Patilla-Brownson.
Sorry, can you hear me here?
Yes, thank you.
Okay, I got that.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Here.
Member Olken.
Member McQuillan.
Here.
Member Lewis.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Escobedo.
President Darling-Hammond.
Here.
Member Bonacca.
We have a quorum.
And just as a brief reminder,
as we come back from the break,
for those that may have called in,
that we are dealing right now with the waivers on consent,
items W1 through W19.
If you're calling about a subsequent item,
please hang up and call back in for that item.
Thank you.
And Brooks, I don't know if you intend to be off video,
but we are not seeing you on video right now.
I do intend to be.
Okay.
So is there any public comment?
Yes, it looks like we do have some public comment.
And again, this is for W1 through 19,
the waiver consent calendar.
I will open the phone line now.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller.
Go ahead, caller.
This is former Governor Jerry Brown.
I want to speak very briefly to the Samora Beach Academy.
This is an extra charter.
Apologies, Governor Brown,
but that's actually gonna be on a subsequent item.
Right now we're dealing only with our waiver items.
Okay, so do I call in or do I just stay on the phone?
You can just call back in after we finish this up.
Okay, so I hang up and then just call back, same number?
Yes, please, sir.
Thank you.
Okay, good.
Okay, next caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller, ending with the last one.
Am I on now?
You are.
Please go ahead with your public comment.
My name is Lisa Kimada from Monabella Teachers.
I'm calling in opposition to allowing the time charter
any further opening to Monabella.
Oh, I apologize.
I apologize.
We are currently taking public comment
for waiver consent items W1 through W19.
If we just ask if you could please call back
in a couple minutes, okay?
Okay.
Thank you very much.
And it looks like that concludes public comment
for the waiver items.
All right.
Thank you very much.
At this point, given that there's no other public comment,
I now ask for a motion on waivers one through 19.
So moved.
Second?
Second.
Terrific.
We'll now have a roll call vote.
Brooks, will you please call the roll?
Member Rodriguez.
Aye.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Member Olken.
Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Member Lewis.
Yes.
Vice President Clever-Woods.
Member Escobedo.
Yes.
President Darlene Hammond.
Member Bonanca.
Aye.
Motion carries.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
We're gonna move on to item 16.
Item 16 is the appeal of the denial of a petition
for the establishment of a classroom-based charter school
pursuant to California Education Code Section 47605K2.
And the California Department of Education recommends
that the State Board of Education hear the SBA appeal.
This recommendation is based on CDE's review of the appeal
and the documentary record.
SBA has submitted sufficient evidence to hear the appeal
and there are no grounds to summarily deny
per the recommendation.
This item will be presented by Stephanie Farland of the CDE.
Stephanie, please begin.
Good morning, President Darlene Hammond,
board members, chief, deputy, nicely.
Let's go in here.
So we are here to hear this item,
which is to ask the State Board to hear
or summarily deny the appeal of Samoa Beach Academy.
Little background on this item.
The Samoa Beach Academy petition
proposes a new grade nine through 12 charter school.
The petitioner submitted its petition
to the Northern Humboldt Union High School District
pursuant to Ed Code 47605A.
The district denied the petition on September 14th, 2021
by a vote of five to zero.
SBA then appealed to the denial
to the Humboldt County Board of Education
pursuant to Ed Code section 47605K1AI.
The county denied the petition on February 9th, 2022
by a vote of five to zero.
The charter petitioners then submitted its petition
on appeal to the California State Board of Education
on March 11th, 2022 pursuant to Ed Code section 47605K2.
As stated, the Department of Education is recommending
that the State Board hear the SBA appeal.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools
pursuant to 47605K2D will hold a public hearing
to review the appeal and documentary record
and shall submit a recommendation to the State Board
whether there is sufficient evidence to hear the appeal
or to summarily deny review of the appeal
based on the documentary record.
The ACCS did, at its June 14th meeting,
hear the appeal, review the documentary record,
and the ACCS accepted the CDE recommendation
and moved to recommend that the SBE hear the SBA appeal.
The motion was passed on a vote of seven to one.
The SBA has submitted all required documents
and met all timelines pursuant to Ed Code section 47605K2A.
It submitted its appeal, a record of the findings
from the district and county, and a written submission
with citations to the documentary record.
NHUHSD and HCBOE provided written oppositions
with specific citations to the documentary record
pursuant to Ed Code section 47605K2C.
The aforementioned documents demonstrate
that there is a factual dispute concerning
the district and county's decisions to deny SBA's petition.
Based on the CDE's review of all documents,
the CDE finds sufficient evidence
for the SBE to hear the appeal.
In this item, the SBE shall decide to either
hear the appeal or summarily deny a review of the appeal
based on the documentary record.
If the SBE decides to hear the appeal,
as recommended by the CDE and ACCS,
the matter will be considered in the following item.
So as we stated, the CDE recommends
that the SBE hear the SBA appeal.
And as I stated earlier, the ACCS
will decide to either hear the appeal
and as I stated earlier, the ACCS at its June 14th meeting
accepted that recommendation and moved also
to recommend that the SBE hear the SBA appeal.
Are you done with your presentation?
I'm done with my presentation.
Okay, thank you.
So we have the public comment slide now
and we will open the phone line for the public comment queue.
The item is limited to a decision
as to whether or not to hear the appeal.
People wishing to make comments on the merits of the appeal
should please wait and comment on the next item,
which is item 17.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item may do so by calling the telephone number
and using the access code provided on the slide
that is shown now.
While we're waiting, I want to ask our liaisons,
Vice President Glover-Woods and Member Olken,
if they have any initial comments.
We'll check then to see if anyone has clarifying questions
and then go to public comment
on whether or not to hear the appeal.
And I'm gonna ask Vice President Glover-Woods
to see if she has any framing comments for us.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
I just wanted to underscore a couple of items
that Director Farland shared with us.
One, the ACCS did have opportunity to hear
from the petitioners as well as a representative
for both the district and the county office
and decide if there was enough evidence for us
to actually hear the appeal itself.
So again, just to underscore the action that we take
on this particular item is to decide to hear the appeal.
It does not have anything to do with the actual merit
of the appeal itself.
Thank you.
And Member Olken, anything you'd like to add at this point?
Yes, thank you.
So I just wanted to add that as the advisory commission
on charter schools was deliberating,
they were grappling a bit with their new role
as described in 1505.
And so it took a little bit of thinking for them
because it's a change in the process.
But as they thought about what their role is,
they concurred with CDE that in fact,
there was enough of a factual dispute
that this should be heard by the state board.
All right, thank you very much.
Are there any clarifying questions from members of the board
before we go to public comment?
I'm seeing no hands raised.
In that case, we'll see if there's any public comment.
We do have some callers in the queue for public comment.
I will open the phone line now.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, thanks for the opportunity
to address the school board.
My name's Tom McMahon.
I am the president of the Humboldt County School Board
and I'm a retired educator with 27 years experience,
all of it in Humboldt County.
My decision to deny the appeal for the Sama Bay Academy
was based on my thorough review of the documents submitted,
my consideration of substantial public input
and the presentations offered by both parties
during the public hearing.
I'm an avid supporter of quality career technical education
for the students and local community,
but I could not support the model and plan
presented by Samoa Beach Academy.
My concerns were the model did not present
a sound educational program for all students,
especially those with special needs and the underprivileged.
The program is highly unlikely to be successfully implemented
due to the unrealistic enrollment projections
and the accompanying budget projections
and the lack of availability
of specialized credentialed teachers
to fill the anticipated need.
I'm sorry, sir.
If you could please,
sorry to interrupt.
If you could please call back for the next item.
We are currently taking public comment for item number 16.
Thank you.
Oh, okay.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
I believe I'm calling for the next item as well.
Okay, thank you very much.
It is confusing.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Good morning, it's Eric Premack
with the Charter Schools Development Center.
I wanna note that by any reasonable process or standard,
the local denial was unlawful and therefore constituted
an abuse of discretion that should be heard today.
Therefore, we do urge the board to vote yes on this item
and hear the public comment.
I will note though that in my 30 years
of working on education policy,
the underlying statutes here are just horribly drafted
and beg a lot of questions
that the board needs to step up and deal with.
We addressed these in the letter
that we shared with the board last week
and we hope that there will be a discussion of these
more thoroughly in the future.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Good morning, my name is Caroline Neuhaus-Wesley
calling from Sephora Education Associates
and I urge the State Board of Education to hear this item.
There is enough evidence that there is a factual dispute
that needs to be discussed.
And since this is the first appeal coming to you
since AB 1505, it is important that the board hear
the appeal to determine the abuse of discretion
as we move forward with charters in the future.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for item number 16.
All right.
Having concluded a public comment,
I wanna open the floor for discussion with the board.
Is there anyone who'd like to ask any questions
or make any comments?
I am seeing no hands going up.
So would someone like to make a motion?
I'll move that we hear the appeal
and align to CDE's recommendation on this item.
I second that.
Thank you very much.
Any other discussion?
Brooks, can you call the roll for the vote?
Member Rodriguez.
Aye.
Member Paquillo-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Member Olken.
Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Member Lewis.
Yes.
Member Rice, President Glover-Woods.
Member Escobedo.
Yes.
President Darling-Hammond.
Member Bonanca.
Aye.
Motion carries.
All right.
Thank you very much, Stephanie.
And now we're gonna move on to item 17.
Item 17 is a public hearing regarding the appeal
of the denial of the petition for the establishment
of the classroom-based charter school
pursuant to California Education Code 47605K2,
consideration of the allegations of abusive discretion
made by Samoa Beach Academy,
which was denied by the Northern Humboldt Union
High School District
and the Humboldt County Board of Education.
The California Department of Education recommends
that the SBE affirm the NHUHSD
and HCBOE decisions to deny the petition
to establish Samoa Beach Academy.
The item will be presented by Stephanie Farland of the CDE.
Stephanie, you may begin.
Thank you.
Good morning again.
In this item, the California State Board of Education
will hear the Samoa Beach Academy appeal
pursuant to California Education Code 47605K2E,
the SBE may either affirm the determination
of the Governing Board of the School District
or the County Board of Education,
or both of those determinations,
or reverse only upon a determination
that there was an abuse of discretion.
In the previous item, the SBE decided to hear the appeal
based on the documentary record.
So for those on the board that are used
to the previous standard of review of appeals,
this will look and feel different.
The CDE is not reviewing the charter petition
as it has in the past.
We're reviewing this written submission
by the charter petitioners with their specific citations
to the documentary record,
and any written opposition from the district and our county
with their specific citations to the record
to determine if there has been an abuse of discretion
by the district or county boards of education or both.
We focus our review on those written submissions.
Each of the appeals that comes before this board
will be reviewed on a case-by-case basis.
The California Department of Education
recommends that the SBE affirm
the Northern Humboldt Union High School Districts
and Humboldt County Board of Education's decisions
to deny the petition to establish SBA,
pursuant to Ed Code Section 47605K2D.
This recommendation is based on the CDE's determination
that the documentary record indicates
that neither the N-H-U-H-S-D
nor the H-C-B-O-E abused its discretion
in denying SBA's petition.
I will most likely be saying district and county
moving forward because those initials
are very hard to say without tripping up.
So there was an information memo
that was posted on June 30th that outlines the SBE's role
under the new appeal and review standards.
I will just cover a few of the points covered in that memo.
The role of the SBE in charter schools
pursuant to Ed Code Section 47605K2E,
the role of the SBE is as follows.
The SBE shall either hear the appeal
or summarily deny review of the appeal
based on the documentary record,
which you did in the previous item.
If the SBE hears the appeal,
the board may affirm the determination
of the governing board of the school district
or the county board of education
or both of those determinations
or may reverse only upon a determination
that there was an abuse of discretion.
Abuse of discretion is the most
deferential standard of review.
The SBE is required to give deference to the decision
of the school district governing board
and county board of education to deny the petition.
The SBE's review is limited to a determination
of whether the district governing boards
or county board's decision to deny the charter petition
was arbitrary, capricious, entirely lacking
in evidentiary support, unlawful, or procedurally unfair.
The CDE's review of SBA's written submission,
which detailed with specific citations
to the documentary record,
how the governing board of the school district
and the county board of education abused their discretion.
The CDE also reviewed the documentary record
as cited by SBA in their written submission,
districts and county's findings
and the districts and county's opposition.
Based on its review, the CDE will make a recommendation
to the state board to either affirm or reverse
the decisions of the governing board
of the school district and the county
based on the presence or absence of an abuse of discretion
in the denial of the charter petition.
So now we will move into Samoa Beach Academy's allegations
of abuse of discretion.
SBA states that the district and county's decisions
to deny the charter petition
are not supported by substantial evidence.
SBA's written submission detailing
the specific allegations regarding the district's findings
can be found on pages 560 to 560 of the SBA's report.
Can be found on pages 562 to 580 of the documentary record
from the HCBOE.
SBA's written submission detailing
the specific allegations regarding HCBOE's findings
can be found on page 537 to 552
of the documentary record from the county.
So all of the detailed information regarding their claims
can be found in item attachment one.
And we will be going into some detail in later slides.
SBA states that the district and county
did not proceed in the matter required by law
and therefore abused their discretion
in denying SBA's petition.
The district failed to comply with equal time
and procedures guarantees.
The district and county each failed to comply
with statutory requirement to maintain
and produce a transcript record.
And the county impermissibly denied the charter petition
on the basis that SBA did not re-obtain signatures.
Districts and counties oppositions to SBA's appeal.
NHUHSD's opposition states that its denial of SBA's petition
was based on evidence demonstrating
the following findings.
You can find that on pages six through 22.
The SBA presents an unsound educational program
for the pupils to be enrolled in the charter school
and the petitioners are demonstrably unlikely
to successfully implement the program
set forth in the petition.
Additionally, the district argues that the procedural claims
and SBA's appeal do not demonstrate
an abuse of discretion.
The county, did I skip a slide, no I didn't, okay.
The county opposition to SBA's appeal.
HCBOE's opposition states that it did not abuse
its discretion by not recording the meeting
at which SBA's petition was denied
and that its findings in support of denying SBA's petition
met all requirements of the law
and that could be found in their opposition letter
pages four to nine.
The county denied SBA's petition
based on the following findings.
The SBA petition presents an unsound educational program
for the pupils to be enrolled in the charter school.
The petitioners are demonstrably unlikely
to successfully implement the program
set forth in the petition.
The petition does not contain the number
of signatures required.
Based on the CDE's review of SBA's written submission,
documentary record, and supporting documentation
and the NHUHSD's and HCBOE's opposition,
the CDE has determined that the district and county
did not abuse their discretion
in the denial of the SBA petition.
A summary of the district and county's findings
regarding the SBA petition,
SBA's allegations of abuse of discretion
and the district and county's oppositions
are all provided in attachment one.
CDE's review of district's findings.
After reviewing the documentary record
and supporting documentation
submitted by the parties to this appeal,
the CDE has determined that NHUHSD's findings
were supported by evidence.
NHUHSD based their decision to deny SBA's charter
on the following findings,
which were supported by evidence
in the documentary record.
The charter school presents an unsound educational program
for the pupils to be enrolled in the charter school.
The petitioners are demonstrably unlikely
to successfully implement the program
set forth in the petition.
The district finding of unsound educational program.
The district's written finding set forth specific facts
based on evidence in the documentary record,
including, but not limited to,
proposed course offerings and staffing plans
raise concerns that the educational program
is not likely to be of educational benefit to students.
SBA's budgeted per special education pupil spending
is lower than comparable schools in the area
and does not account for transportation
or an alternative placement.
The petition's description
of the special education program
includes the use of paraprofessionals
are not included in the petition's budget.
SBA proposes both resource specialist program services
and special day class placements,
but their staffing plan includes
only a single education teacher.
The district finding of demonstrably unlikely
to successfully implement the program.
The district's written finding set forth specific facts
based on evidence in the documentary record,
including, but not limited to.
SBA's special education budget includes errors
in calculating special education revenues
for unduplicated students.
SBA's budget assumes they will not need
to serve severe students that produce related high costs.
As an independent charter, one high cost student
could be devastating to a budget with virtually no reserve.
Several figures in SBA's cash flow projections
are unclear as to how the calculations were reached.
High facilities costs will require SBA's enrollment
to grow at a rate far exceeding most charter schools.
The multi-tiered system of support, MTSS,
is a framework requiring collaborative work,
robust use of data, intensive training,
and professional development.
The petition proposes only a .5 full-time
equivalent counselor to support MTSS.
The petition budget does not allocate
specific funding for MTSS.
The petition's proposed teacher compensation
is less competitive than other local employers.
The CDE reviewed the county's findings.
After reviewing the complete documentary record
and supporting documentation submitted
by the parties to this appeal, the CDE has determined
that two of HCBOE's three findings were supported
by evidence in the documentary record.
The charter school presents an unsound educational program
for the pupils to be enrolled in the charter school,
and the petitioners are demonstrably unlikely
to successfully implement the program
set forth in the petition.
476056C states that the governing board
must make written findings setting forth specific facts
to support one or more findings
when they review a charter petition.
The county finding of unsound educational program.
The county's written findings set forth specific facts
based on evidence in the documentary record,
including but not limited to.
The design of SBA's career technical education program
limits student choice and is likely
to compromise student engagement.
Proposed course offerings and staffing plans
raise concerns that the educational program
is not likely to be of educational benefit to students.
MTSS is not a specific intervention,
but instead is a framework around
which evidence-based interventions are built.
Instead, the petition gives a formula
for when certain interventions are used.
The proposed program emphasizes supporting students
through MTSS and restorative practices.
Staff in the program must have designated time
and effective training to implement the petition.
SBA underestimates the likely English learner percentage
based on its proposed location,
and is unclear how the proposed program
can support a larger EL population.
Continuing with the unsound educational program findings,
the county writes the petition proposes
a resource specialist program model of services
with push-in and pull-out services,
and a special day class, and online specialist programs,
all taught and or coordinated by a single teacher.
SBA's special education description
includes the use of paraprofessionals,
but the budget does not include
funding for paraprofessionals.
The petition proposes to secure
the special education staff and services
as needed with assistance from SBA's SELPA
and or County Office of Education.
But the petitioners have not reached out
to the humble Del Norte SELPA
or the El Dorado County Charter SELPA
regarding membership and or what supports
could be provided by the SELPA.
SBA's budget does not account for realistic costs
associated with special education
in the first year of operations.
The petition's budget did not include costs
that accurately reflect the scope for the MEALS program.
The county finding for demonstrably unlikely
to successfully implement program.
The county's written finding set forth specific facts
based on evidence in the documentary record,
including, but not limited to,
SBA projects unrealistic enrollment
that far exceeds the enrollment
of charter schools in the area.
SBA projects a 95% attendance rate
which exceeds local high school averages
in both local districts,
leading to over projection of LCFF funds.
SBA's petition does not indicate any student support
shown to increase attendance.
SBA's special education budget includes errors
in calculating special education revenues
for unduplicated students,
and there is no budget for food service staff,
maintenance custodial staff,
paraprofessional staff, or a secretary registrar,
each of which are contemplated in the petition.
The petition states that food services will be outsourced.
However, the budget does not account for staffing
to heat and serve meals or to supervise meal times.
In addition, SBA's proposed lease
includes an annual increase
but does not reflect a standard percentage-based increase.
Lease cost for the five-year term as follows,
and it is on the screen.
In addition to rent and utilities,
SBA's lease requires SBA to pay all property expenses,
including real estate tax,
building insurance, and maintenance.
Continuing under demonstratively unlikely
to successfully implement program,
the county finds SBA's petition
does not indicate how the petitioners
will overcome the difficulty of hiring qualified teachers,
especially CTE teachers in Humboldt County,
where the teacher shortage is potentially leading
to a CTE program crisis.
SBA's proposed staffing plan includes a greater workload
and lower compensation than local areas,
schools, and districts.
SBA's former lead petitioner and executive director,
Katherine Scott, has withdrawn from the charter.
SBA's proposed program of integrated core course content
and CTE standards require the necessary background
to ensure successful implementation of that program.
Petitioners have not indicated who will serve
as the school's executive director.
The CDE also reviewed the claims of procedural violations.
SBA alleges that there are procedural violations
and that each violation constitutes an abuse of discretion.
Ed Code section 47605 K2E requires
the State Board of Education to determine
whether the district's and county's decisions
to deny the SBA petition in totality
constitute an abuse of discretion.
The CDE does not find that the procedural violations
alleged give rise to a determination
that there was an abuse of discretion.
Equivalent time and procedures.
And so these are the alleged violations submitted by SBA.
Ed Code section 47605 B states,
at the public hearing at which the governing board
of the school district will either grant or deny the charter,
petitioners shall have equivalent time and procedures
to present evidence and testimony
to respond to the staff recommendations and findings.
SBA did not meet their burden of showing
how the district did not provide equivalent time and procedures.
For example, the district staff asked petitioners
if 10 minutes were enough for petitioners' presentation
and petitioners agreed.
And all this can be found in the documentary record
in the pages that are listed.
Petitioners presented for approximately 11 minutes.
District staff and legal counsel presented approximately 26 minutes.
However, district staff did not limit petitioners' time.
The district board members deliberated and heard answers
to their questions of district staff and legal counsel.
Neither N-H-U-H-S-D nor H-C-B-O-E produced a written transcript.
However, SBA has not made any claims
indicating how the absence of a transcript
impacted the district or county's denial of SBA's petition.
After reviewing the complete documentary record
and supporting documentation submitted by the parties
to this appeal, the CDE has determined
that neither the N-H-U-H-S-D nor H-C-B-O-E
abused their discretion in reaching their decisions
to deny SBA's charter petition.
Therefore, the CDE recommends the SBE affirm N-H-U-H-S-Ds
and H-C-B-O-E's decisions to deny SBA's charter petition.
And that concludes my presentation.
Thank you very much, Stephanie.
We're going to open the public hearing.
I hereby open the public hearing at 9.55 a.m.
We will hear first from petitioners representing
Samoa Beach Academy Charter School.
They will have 12 minutes to make their presentation.
We will then hear from Northern Humboldt Union High School
and the Humboldt County Office of Education,
who denied the charter appeal.
They will have 12 minutes to make their presentation.
The district and county will have a combined total of 12 minutes,
to be clear.
After the presentation, we'll open up the phone line
for public comment from individuals
who are not part of the presentation.
The petitioner may begin. You have 12 minutes.
Our video has been turned off.
I guess we need to ask the folks
who are managing the technology to turn you on.
Thank you.
You're on.
Okay, thank you very much.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond and board members.
My name is David Lawn, and I am the lead petitioner
and a board member for the Samoa Beach Academy.
As a career educator, I've spent close to four years
in the Samoa Beach Academy.
I've spent close to four years in education in various roles,
from classified positions as an instructional aide and custodian,
to a certificated positions as a teacher,
athletic director, coach, and administrator,
including as an assistant superintendent
in the Northern Humboldt Union High School District.
I currently am working in education as an administrative coach,
helping educators complete their administrative credential.
I'm so pleased to be a part of the extremely well-qualified
petitioning team behind the proposed charter school
that we are supporting.
Samoa Beach Academy will bring much needed full-time CTE programs
in Humboldt County that will accommodate the needs
of so many students in our area.
SBA is focused on individual students.
Janelle, I think you can go to the next slide, please.
Thank you.
As we will be a small high school with small class sizes,
SBA will offer three CTE pathways,
including residential and commercial construction,
patient care, and business management.
SBA is committed to career skills and financial literacy
with internship opportunities and required courses.
Finally, SBA will offer both college and career-bound programs,
allowing students to meet A2G requirements and CTE coursework.
Now, we'd like to hand over our presentation to our legal counsel.
We feel this is important due to the legal changes
and how the state considers charter appeals.
Thank you, Dave, and good morning,
Board President Darling-Hammond, board members.
My name is Janelle Ruhle.
I'm an attorney with the law offices of Young, Minion Corps.
I'm certain that you're going to hear a lot today
about the importance of your vote,
and I will lend my voice to that chorus.
I can assure you that a lot of folks, including a lot of lawyers,
are going to be paying attention to today's outcome.
As we work through the issues,
I know that we will all be mindful of precedent.
We ask you today to determine that the district and county
abuse their discretion in denying the Samoa Beach Academy Charter
and to therefore reverse those denial decisions.
We ask that you take action to guard the protections
that we want in the law.
We ask that you ensure meaningful appeals.
I am so proud to represent Samoa Beach Academy.
The team behind this charter petition
is full of committed business owners, volunteers, and educators
who are passionate about increasing choice for students
and creating a viable career path for them.
This part of the state is desperately in need of trained workers.
I have no doubt Samoa can deliver them.
This is a charter school that will succeed.
So this morning, we'll talk about defining abuse of discretion,
the role of the state board,
and then applying the definition to Samoa Beach.
First up, defining abuse of discretion.
It's important to have a definition
so that we know what it is that we're aiming for.
We know what our target is.
Without a definition, we just don't even know where to begin.
So as we've heard, this term is not defined in the Ed Code,
the Charter Schools Act.
We don't have regulations yet in this area.
So we look to statute and case law.
Samoa Beach is proposing a definition
that comes from the Code of Civil Procedure as well as case law
that an abuse of discretion is established when the agency,
one, has not proceeded in a manner required by law,
two, the order or decision is not supported by the findings,
or three, the findings are not supported by evidence.
So the or is important there,
and I'll come back to that a little later.
The CDE's definition, also up on the screen,
has five prongs, arbitrary, capricious,
entirely lacking in evidentiary support,
unlawful, or procedurally unfair.
Again, that definition also includes an or.
So in practical terms, we don't see these two definitions
as very far off from one another.
So we're not here today to argue against the CDE's proposed definition.
In fact, there really is some clear overlap
between the two definitions, between the standards.
And the prongs that are at issue for Samoa
are precisely the ones that are overlapping,
that they're in the middle.
So I mentioned the or in the two different standards.
Having an or legally makes the definitions different
legally makes the definitions disjunctive.
That means that we only need one of those prongs to be triggered
in order to find an abusive discretion.
The district, for example, has to only be arbitrary or capricious,
or entirely lacking in evidentiary support,
or unlawful, or procedurally unfair.
We only need one of those five prongs.
What Samoa is here to show you is that the unlawful prong was triggered
both by the district and the county.
I want to be clear about this.
An unlawful act is an abuse of discretion.
We'll demonstrate five different unlawful acts in this case.
You may hear from others that just procedure,
or mere procedure, or only procedure is somehow not a violation of law.
I heard that myself from the CDE.
You might also hear that a minor violation of law
can simply be shrugged away.
But this is untrue.
When AB 1505 became law,
it enshrined several new protections for charter petitioners and statute.
They're all plainly written with no need for interpretation.
These provisions must be protected today.
Now, I'm not a criminal lawyer,
but I did take criminal law and evidence classes in law school,
where we talked a lot about a concept called the fruit of the poisonous tree.
This concept is evocative.
If the government or a prosecutor does not observe
all procedural rights during an investigation,
then the results of that investigation,
evidence, tips, confession,
all of those things are forever tainted.
They cannot be relied upon for a conviction.
If the tree is poisoned,
the fruit that comes from it is poisoned.
This concept is echoed in civil law.
If a school district or charter school governing board
posts the agenda for their regular meeting only 71 hours in advance,
the entire meeting is unlawful under the Brown Act.
Any actions taken in that meeting would be void.
No one would argue with a straight face that 72 hours
is really just a minor provision of the Brown Act.
Even this appeal you heard from CDE,
if we hadn't gotten this appeal in timely,
we wouldn't be here before you today.
These things have to make a difference.
They have to matter.
So CDE's approach appears to be the exact opposite,
where if they find just one piece of fruit from that tree is ripe,
then the whole tree must be healthy and nothing else matters.
So we argue, again, the opposite.
Procedural protections are vital to citizens and entities.
They're enshrined in statute,
just like the ones that we're talking about this morning,
and they cannot be dismissed as just procedural protections.
These are laws and the meaning behind them has to be there.
So the role of the state board,
you've heard that it's different,
you're experiencing now that it's different.
State board no longer gets to review a charter with fresh eyes.
Making its own findings around educational soundness,
reasonably comprehensive,
and the other standards that you're used to.
Now the state board's role is limited to evaluating
whether the district or county, or both,
abuse their discretion and denying the charter.
That means that we're confined to the underlying record.
The state board is more like an umpire now,
rather than a trier of fact.
In that umpire role,
the board is bound to follow the law
and to reverse the denials if it finds abuse of discretion.
So the CDE, they actually did conclude
that the district and county violated the law.
That was in some of their findings in their report.
Inexplicably though,
they've decided that violating the law
is not sufficient for meeting the unlawful prong.
The CDE appears to conclude again
that if there was at least one element of factual accuracy
in the denials, some good fruit,
then there could not possibly be an abuse of discretion,
no matter how many other laws were violated.
This approach taken to its logical conclusion
means that virtually no charter appeal
will ever result in reversal
if there's even one shred of legal accuracy in the record.
We're asking you today to act independently
and reverse these denials.
If you don't, it will be a death knell
to the procedural protections for charter petitioners
that are written into statute.
If you do not reverse here with clearly legal violations,
no school district or county anywhere in the state,
any time will follow any of these requirements.
There simply won't be any consequences
for not following them.
Okay, so what are these abuses?
The first abuse is that the district did not comply
with the equal time guarantees during the decision meeting.
Samoa got about 11 minutes to present
and the district staff and council took 31 minutes,
nearly three times as long.
You've heard that Samoa only asked for 10 minutes.
That's true.
We got an open-ended question.
How long do you think you need?
We said 10 minutes because that's what's most common.
It was on the district conform to what we said.
If we said 10 minutes and we took 10 minutes,
then they needed to limit themselves to 10 minutes.
They didn't do that.
The loss is equal time.
Samoa didn't get in.
Therefore, there's an abuse of discretion.
Abuse number two, the district failed to comply
with equal equivalent procedure guarantees as well.
They never posted Samoa's response to the staff report
with their meeting agenda.
If we don't have any belief or expectation
that the district board members read our responses,
but they did read the staff report,
which was posted with the agenda,
there's no way that we can know
that we had equivalent procedures.
And if the district didn't read our responses,
of course their decision was prejudiced.
Abuse number three, the district and county each failed
to comply with the legal requirement
to prepare a transcript.
The CDE is trying to say that it doesn't matter
that there's no transcript, but it does.
The ACCS almost derailed this whole thing.
There were commissioners from the ACCS
who wanted to throw out the entire appeal
because there was no transcript,
because they see this like an expulsion appeal.
And if there's no transcript on an expulsion appeal,
you have no idea whether or not the underlying triers
of facts actually followed what the law was.
So the transcript is extremely important.
And the CDE made a decree that a transcript can be a video,
but it's just simply not true.
A transcript can be made from a video,
but a video is not a transcript.
Transcript is a writing.
It's something you can print out
and put in a binder and read.
So not having the transcript nearly derailed this appeal.
The fourth abuse of discretion is that the county board
made up out of thin air a new reason for denial
and then denied the charter because of that.
We simply don't have a requirement
to gather new signatures at the appeal stage.
The CDE found that this was a violation as well.
And then last, abuse number five.
If somehow I haven't convinced you about procedure,
and I hope that I have,
many of the district's findings,
many of the county's findings,
the CDE independently found had actually no merit to them.
And without any merit,
without being based on facts or law,
those findings were not sufficient to deny the charter.
So just some examples.
These are findings that were not supported,
that the charter school will provide inferior CTE,
that online instruction is not high quality,
that recruitment of teachers would be a barrier to success,
that the school has not accounted for special ed services,
needs to hire more than one special ed teacher,
that there are four CTE programs in the district
that are thriving and it's unlikely that...
Thank you, your time is up.
Thank you very much.
President Darling-Hammond, I apologize, I think you're on mute.
We are now going to hear from the Northern Humboldt Union High School
and Humboldt County Office of Education for a combined 12 minutes.
Hi, good morning, State Board of Education.
My name is Jennifer Nix.
I'm the attorney representing the Humboldt County Board of Education,
as well as the Humboldt County Office of Education.
I'm here today with the Humboldt County Superintendent of Schools,
Michael Davis Hughes,
on behalf of both the Northern Humboldt Union High School District
and the Humboldt County Board of Education
to ask you to affirm the denials of this charter petition.
The SBA petitioners were denied a charter school
because two different local boards found that the program
the petition seeks to provide will be a detriment to children,
is financially unviable,
and will funnel a significant amount of public funds to a private company.
The Northern Humboldt High School District
and the Humboldt County Board of Education
did not make this decision quickly or lightly.
Instead, they had staff conduct thorough reviews of the petition,
including meeting with the petitioners
and researching all of the claims in the petition.
Both boards held two separate public hearings
with extensive public input at each meeting prior to making their decisions.
SBA wants to make this appeal about alleged minor issues in the process.
However, minor procedural hiccups in a charter school process
cannot override the fact that this school
would be harmful to the students of Humboldt County,
even if the petitioners found a way to make it financially viable.
Of course, you all know that AB 1505 changed the standard for appeals
and how you review appeals.
That change of standard was designed to emphasize
local control over decision-making with regard to charter school petitions
and to put in place a system where those local decisions
were not overturned unless the local school district
and the county board were both derelict in their duties under the law.
CDE has recommended that you define abuse of discretion as arbitrary, capricious,
entirely lacking in evidentiary support, unlawful, or procedurally unfair.
We, the LEAs, agree with that definition
because it is the definition that courts have been applying
to review school district decisions with regard to charter schools for many years now.
However, regardless of the definition that you choose for abuse of discretion,
SBA did not and cannot show that there was an abuse of discretion
here by either LEA, much less both of them.
The record is clear that both LEAs acted in a reasonable manner.
Both LEAs supported their decisions with lengthy factual findings
citing to the record and any procedural concerns
either are not grounded in what's required in the law or did not cause harm to the petitioners.
Northern Humboldt based their decision to deny SBA's charter on two findings.
First, that the charter school presented an unsound educational program
for the students enrolled in the charter school.
And second, that the petitioners were demonstrably unlikely
to successfully implement the program set forth in the petition.
They supported that decision with 12 pages of findings.
Notable in those findings are that the CTE program
that the petition describes would be understaffed
and would rely too heavily on an online curriculum.
Additionally, the budget was not accurate and relied on incorrect assumptions,
including the fact that it did not reflect an understanding
of the programming or costs related to students with disabilities.
You're going to hear that that was a significant concern from the school board,
in part because Humboldt County has one of the highest
percentages of students with disabilities in the state.
The Humboldt County Board of Education based their decision to deny SBA's charter
on three findings.
First, that the charter school presented an unsound educational program,
that the petitioners were demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the program,
and additionally, that the petition did not contain the number of required signatures.
Now, similarly to the district, the county board had concerns with regard to the CTE program,
with regard to the petitioner's ability to implement an integrated CTE program,
and with regard to the staffing, which was unrealistic in concept,
because it relied on a number of part-time teachers,
and in reality, because of a countywide CTE teacher shortage.
Additionally, the county board was concerned that the budget was inaccurate
and relied on incorrect assumptions.
Similar concerns were raised by the county board with regard to the petition's information
regarding supports for students with disabilities,
students with social-emotional deficits,
and the budget to provide supports to those individuals.
The county board also raised two additional concerns.
First is that the petition identified a location or a facility that SBA intended to lease,
that cannot be contracted with without running afoul of government code section 1090,
due to significant conflicts of interest with the building's owner and the Samoa Beach Academy.
The proposed lease, moreover, reflects a gross misuse of public funds,
as it would funnel almost $2.7 million to a private company
within the first five years of SBA's existence.
That lease reflects a space that has a cost far in excess of the facilities
of any other charter school within Humboldt County.
The square foot cost in year five would be almost $35 per square foot,
whereas the maximum cost any other charter school in Humboldt County
is paying for a leased facility is $1.10 per square foot,
almost 35 times the rent.
Additionally, the county board found that the petition did not contain the required signatures.
The petition was required to have four signatures from four meaningfully interested teachers.
The county office of education contacted the four individuals who were listed,
well, three of them.
One of them did not have a phone number.
Only one of them was actually interested in teaching at SBA,
and that individual does not hold a California teaching credential.
One individual indicated he had been interested in teaching at SBA,
but was no longer interested.
One individual indicated that he was never interested in teaching at SBA
and that he had misunderstood what his signature meant.
To be clear, when the county board found that the petition
did not contain the required signatures,
they were looking at the signatures on the face of the petition,
not at any additional requirement.
County office staff did acknowledge the passage of time as permitted by the education code
and permit petitioners to provide additional signatures,
but they chose not to do so.
The LEAs both issued extensive factual findings
that cannot be said to be entirely lacking in evidentiary support.
They also can't be said to not reflect substantial evidence supporting their decision.
So turning to the procedural violations that are alleged,
SBA can't point to any procedural error that actually rises to an abuse of discretion,
because minor procedural errors do not rise to an abuse of discretion.
The LEAs are requesting that the SBA affirm the denial of the charter petition
unless there are significant issues regarding the review and appeal process at the local level.
To adopt SBA's argument that any procedural error would require the SBA
to grant the charter petition would result in petitions that are
substantively deficient like this one being granted.
This likely would cause SBA to grant more appeals than before AB 1505 was enacted,
which is clearly contradictory to the legislative intent.
So I want to talk about the alleged procedural violations.
The procedure in the code requires equal time and procedures,
and that was given to the petitioners.
The school district, Northern Humboldt Union High School District,
did produce a transcript on appeal.
Second, there's concerns raised that the response to the staff findings was not properly provided
to the board, but SBA actually provided that response directly to the school board members
via email.
Finally, there are concerns raised with regard to equal time.
However, as you heard Miss Rowley admit,
the SBA petitioners were offered as much time as they wanted to present.
They requested 10 minutes, they took 11 minutes,
and they never requested more time even when the school district took additional time.
Importantly, none of these allegations of procedural unfairness against the district
are tied to any alleged harm.
They simply present these allegations and ask for the deficient charter petition to be granted
because of these procedural concerns that did not cause any harm.
With regard to the County Board of Education,
Miss Rowley is correct that the county board did not record the board meeting
at which the SBA petition was denied.
However, that requirement is not in the code.
Education Code Section 47605 Subdivision B
provides the procedural requirements that the school district and the county have to follow
with regard to charter school petitions and reviewing those petitions.
That code section does not require that the meetings be recorded.
Now, if you look down further in the code,
when you get to the section with regard to appeal to the SBE,
it does note that there should be a transcript provided with the documentary record.
But in every other code section in which a public meeting is required to be recorded,
the code explicitly states that it has to be recorded.
So here we have a code section that is unclear at best.
Regardless, SBA does not allege any harm that occurred because the meeting was not recorded.
The harm that we would be looking for in this situation
would be that you, the SBE, are not able to review something that happened at the meeting
that was erroneous or that was unlawful.
However, there's been no allegation that the County Board of Education did
anything that was erroneous or unlawful in that meeting,
just that they failed to actually record it.
Accordingly, we the LEAs are requesting that you find that neither LEA abused their discretion
and that you affirm the decision to deny this charter petition.
And I'm going to turn it over to Mr. Davies-Hughes to conclude.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond, members of the Board.
My name is Michael Davies-Hughes.
I'm the Superintendent of Schools for Humboldt County.
We want to conclude by stating that Humboldt County is home
to many successful charter schools and thriving CTE programs.
Indeed, both the Northern Humboldt High School District
and the Humboldt County Office of Education are authorizers of charter schools.
And we recognize the positive ways in which they support
the diverse needs of students we serve.
However, the Samoa Beach Academy charter petition
falls short of the standards we expect for charter schools in Humboldt County.
And therefore, we cannot support its establishment.
We thank you for your thoughtful consideration.
And I ask that you take action to adopt the recommendations of CTE
and affirm the denials of both the District and the County Board of Education.
Thank you very much.
At this point, I think we want to open the phone line for public comment.
Is the public comment slide up?
Great. I see it.
Public comment. There we go.
Public comment is limited to one minute.
It's for people who are not part of either presentation.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item
may do so by calling the telephone number
and using the access code provided on the slide that is shown now.
As we listen for public comment, we encourage you to please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Please remember to turn down the speaker volume of your computer
if you are following the live feed.
Speakers will be limited to a minute each.
Are there any public comments?
Yes, we have a number of callers in the queue.
I will open the phone line now.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, I'm Dr. Fred Van Vleck and I'm in my 11th years as Superintendent of Eureka City Schools.
Eureka City Schools is a proud sponsor of other independent charter schools
and we are not anti-charter.
I'm a former Career and Tactical Education teacher myself
and I understand quality CTE programs.
I am a graduate of the NHUHSD and a native to the North Coast.
I'm a state certified business official
and a former Assistant Superintendent of Business Services
where I successfully led a district through the Great Recession.
My concern is the fiscal solvency of the SBA charter.
The worst thing that can happen for students is if they open,
start educating students and they close leaving students deeply impacted.
This charter is not set up for fiscal success.
Bottom line, Eureka High School has over half of its 1,200 student population
enrolled in a high quality CTE program
taught by highly qualified and credentialed CTE teachers
including a brand new over $7 million CTE facility.
While the SBA charter is a fine concept,
the reality of the fiscal solvency is a dream.
Please support the recommendation of the CTE staff to affirm
the local decision of the district and county boards of education
who know our community needs best.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Ericka Goldsbury.
I am clerk to the board of the Northern Humboldt Union High School District.
I'm proud to be here with our history of authorizing three charter schools
and our devotion to career technical education.
And I believe when I voted and still believe that it is in the best interest
of students and families in our region to deny the approval of SBA.
As a board member, and I'm aware this is true of my colleagues as well,
I reviewed hundreds of pages of documents including the petition,
the district staff's recommended findings,
and SBA's response to the district initial findings
SBA emailed directly to us.
We listened carefully to SBA's presentation.
First of its initial withdrawn petition and then its second similar petition,
which is before you now, when we voted to deny.
And while the concept of SBA may be laudable aspirationally,
my deeper review of the budget and petition revealed too many concerning gaps
in experience and preparation for us to responsibly allow it to move forward.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
This is former Governor Jerry Brown.
My essential point here is the great difficulty that 1505 has now created.
Your role in reviewing the very important arguments that both sides can make
is now foreclosed and limited by this very legalistic term abuse of discretion.
The result, I'm afraid, is the continuing denial of all new charters
and massive rejection of charter renewals statewide.
So I would ask you, as you make this determination,
to make very clear the inadequacy of this standard review.
You ought to look at the merits, hear both sides,
and be able to make a substantive decision,
not engage in these very legalistic back and forth.
Charter schools play an important role as do our public school system.
I think we have an unfortunate law, and the legislature ought to be modifying it
so we can be fair to the public schools and the charter schools
that so many enthusiastic citizens want to create.
That's my point.
It's a very tough situation that you've now put in
because the law does not allow you to make a full review.
You're limited to finding basically legal nitpicking
with the law following exactly or not.
That's not the way to run a railroad,
and I hope this board will fully probe into what is the situation on review.
That very American fundamental right that no decision at a local level
can never be reviewed at a higher level.
That's a very un-American approach, but there it is,
and only the legislature can change it.
But this school board can illuminate the issues at stake
and can be vigilant in protecting our public schools
and the very creative charter schools that the law makes available,
or at least used to make available.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much, Governor Brown.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
This is Leif Gill.
I am the chapter consultant of the Northern Humboldt High School Teachers Association
and the Eureka Teachers Association.
I support the CDE staff recommendation to affirm the Northern Humboldt School Board
and Humboldt County Board of Ed denials of the charter petition for the Samoa Beach Academy.
Both the district and the county had strong reasons to deny that were well founded.
Humboldt County is in long-term declining enrollment.
The elementary school in Samoa uses only a fraction of its classrooms.
Eureka City Schools has closed several elementary sites
and has lost about 40% of its enrollment over the last few decades.
Most secondary schools in the county have shrunk over the past 20 years.
There is no demand for new schools.
Samoa Beach Academy's budget for staffing is insufficient
to attract and retain qualified teachers from existing schools to switch.
It is also insufficient to compete with private industry for people with the
necessary background and qualifications as CTE teachers.
The existing high schools in the area, Eureka High and Arcata High,
have invested millions of dollars in facilities
and offer locally competitive wages and benefits packages.
Even so, Eureka High School is losing CTE teachers.
Thank you, Collie. Your time is up.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond and esteemed board members.
My name is Tina Plait from the California Charter Schools Association.
We appreciate the care that the department put into coming up with
a definition for abuse of discretion using existing statutes.
However, we're very concerned that the department clearly acknowledged
that the district and county violated the law, as you heard in the presentation,
but then also stated that the actions of the district and county were not unlawful.
We cannot undermine some of the core tenets of AB 1505 in ensuring a fair process for charter
approval by allowing a violation of law around process to be accessible.
Any violation by a district or county of process set forth in statute is unlawful
and a clear abuse of discretion.
Therefore, we respectfully request that you overturn the local decisions.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
My name is Tom McMahon.
I'm the president of the Humboldt County School Board,
and I'm a retired educator with 27 years of experience at all of it in Humboldt County.
My decision to deny the appeal by Samoa Bay Academy was based on my thorough review
of the documents submitted, my consideration of substantial public input, and the presentations
offered by both parties during the public hearings.
I'm an avid supporter of quality career technical education for the students and our community,
but I could not support the model and plan presented by Samoa Beach Academy.
Concerns were the model didn't present a sound education program for all students,
especially those with special needs and the underprivileged program was highly unlikely
to be successfully implemented due to unrealistic enrollment projections and accompanying budget
projections and the lack of ability of specialized credentialed teachers to fill the anticipated need
for full staffing.
Thank you for your time and careful consideration of this matter.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
My name is Siva Kordamanj.
I'm a fifth generation resident and business owner of Humboldt County.
I support the Samoa Beach Academy for many reasons.
First, with Cal Poly set to add 10,000 students in the following years,
Humboldt does need more schools.
With the additions of students, professors, and families, who is going to build the housing
and work in our hospitals?
SBA will ensure their education directly ties into career readiness preparation.
Second, as a business owner who works directly with these businesses in the trade,
I know the businesses end up teaching everything on the job or hiring workers from out of the
area who have experience.
Workers with skill, confidence, and mindfulness in these trades are safer.
Third, this charter proposal represents a unique public-private partnership and we need more
innovation like this in Humboldt County.
I hope the state sees that because if you don't, we are failing our community and kids.
Lastly, I have full confidence in the board, every single person on the board,
and behind the scenes brings experience, confidence, and a work ethic to accomplish
the untouchability of our kids.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Teresa Grosjean and I am the president of the Northern Humboldt Union High
School District Board of Trustees.
I sent public comment to the State Board of Education on July 7th.
In that letter, I detailed dates of hearings and receipts of documents that I received
in preparation of voting on SBA's charter petition.
I also detailed the many factors that I considered and the rationale I used in voting to deny.
Today, I want to reiterate that SBA had ample time to present information to our board.
They received the amount of time they asked for that I had thoroughly on multiple occasions
read all the materials they provided to us, including their petition and response to our
district findings.
I listened to all public comment, made for and against approval, and carefully considered
their petition.
In the end, based on nearly nine years of serving as a board member in my community,
and what I know to be true about the needs of the students in our district, I was convinced
by the evidence that SBA had not created a sound educational program and would be unable
to adequately serve the students of Humboldt County and that it was demonstrable.
Thank you, caller.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Go ahead, caller.
You are live.
I'm sorry.
We can barely hear you.
Would you mind calling back in?
Thank you very much.
Can you hear me well?
We can hear you now.
Yeah.
I'm a long-term resident of Humboldt County and I support the Snow Beach Academy.
The main reason I'm supporting it today is we were constantly asking our citizens and
our local communities to step up and take a bigger role and responsibility and not only
in our school systems but in our local government and how we conduct ourselves.
This is a perfect example of citizens and people stepping up putting in not only a lot
of money and effort and blood and sweat and tears into creating a better education system
for our children.
That is the main reason why I'm supporting Snow Beach Academy.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Cindy Vickers.
I'm the Director of Fiscal Services for Northern Humboldt Union High School District
and have been in that role for the past 11 years.
I reviewed the budget portion of the Samoa Beach Charter petition
as a member of the district's review team.
I had significant concerns about the fiscal sustainability of SBA.
The startup funding source cited is Charter Asset Management.
This company advances funds to the school with payback coming from future state aid.
State aid is driven by enrollment and ADA.
The enrollment projections were unrealistic which would jeopardize the ability of the SBA
to pay back the funding.
The petition states they will provide food service but does not budget for food service staffing.
There is no transportation budgeted, further reducing ADA potential and not accounting
for legally mandated transportation for special ed students.
There is no budget for special ed paraprofessionals although the petition says they will employ
paraprofessionals.
The budgeted cash balance at the end of year one is approximately $16,000 given the omission
of costs associated with food service, transportation and special ed coupled with the unrealistic
enrollment projection.
$16,000 is inadequate to sustain SBA beyond even year one.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
My name is Colby Smart and I am the Assistant Superintendent of Educational Services at
HDOE.
I would like to comment on the process that we went through in reviewing SBA's petition.
First, we conducted a de novo review.
There were 17 members of the HDOE staff who carefully reviewed the petition from their
own particular domain of expertise including curriculum and instruction, CTE, special education,
MTSS, fiscal, facilities and charter oversight.
The findings of the Humboldt County Office of Education are based on an exhaustive review
by staff who have decades of experience in education.
HDOE has a tradition of supporting CTE and charter schools.
HDOE staff's findings reflect deep structural deficiencies in the petition.
We were tasked with reviewing the petition itself and although there is merit in SBA's
concept and vision, our findings expose significant and concerning flaws.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
My name is Dama Ramour, Council for Northern Humboldt Union High School District.
I would like to respond to the following claims by SBA of alleged procedural errors by the
district.
Two are complete misrepresentations.
Regarding the alleged lack of a transcript, prior to providing SBA with a video transcript,
the district verified with Sandy Ridge at CDE that a video transcript was sufficient.
This email exchange has in the record see page 487 and the SBA has it.
Secondly, regarding the alleged failure to provide SBA's response to the district's
findings, that's not even an illegal requirement.
Furthermore, SBA emailed its response to board members as you've heard today.
About the alleged lack of equitable time, the difference in time is de minimis and SBA
has identified no harm caused.
SBA presented to the board three times by the end of the final meeting.
Any minor procedural deviations in time was more than made up for by the two public hearings
prior to the final meeting plus the 25 minutes of public comment in favor of SBA at the final
meeting.
Thank you, honorable members of the board.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, Madam President and members.
My name is Chris Myers and on behalf of the California School Employees Association,
we are urging the board to affirm the decisions of the Northern Humboldt Union High School
District and the Humboldt County Board of Education to deny this Namoa Beach Academy
Charter Petition.
CSCA agrees with the CDE staff recommendation which concluded that neither LEA abused its
discretion in denying the petition.
It's abundantly clear based on the records before you that both LEAs made well-reasoned
decisions to deny the petition after fairly evaluating the petition, consulting qualified
experts, comparing relevant data, and calling upon their own expertise.
Even in the event of a minor procedural error, it should not then follow that the LEA's decision
be reversed and the petition granted.
The LEA's acted within the letter of the law and completed their due diligence in
fairly evaluating the petition.
Therefore, we urge you to affirm the LEA's decision to deny the Charter Petition.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Rob Flint and I've lived in Arcata since 1984.
I've been in the trade since 1987 when I took my gap year from college.
I support the Samoa Beach Academy because it's the type of education that would have
benefited me.
I think the public schools here are good, but I don't think that they're good for everybody.
There's enough people who would benefit from a trades-based education.
It would be a great symbiotic relationship.
The trades could use an influx of youth with a baseline of knowledge.
I think the students would benefit from having a relevant education for them where they see
the end game and they see the benefit of what they're learning.
I also think that choice is a positive thing and competition is a positive thing too.
The local high school district would benefit from the competition as well.
It makes everybody better.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Steve Brodhag and I run the Danco cabinet shop.
I'm calling to support the Samoa Beach Academy as someone that hires the employees that these
schools put out.
Calling their education anything but mediocre is a gross overstatement.
My best employees were so disgruntled with school that they dropped out.
A school like this can reach children and make them want to go to school.
If I had this, I would have been so much better off than I am now.
These are high paying jobs that these children can get right out of high school without going
to college, without student debt.
It will only help the underprivileged people of our community.
And I feel so strongly about this.
When this school is approved, I plan on getting my teacher's credential and teaching there.
Thank you very much.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello.
My name is Sheila Rocker Heppe and I serve on the Humboldt County Board of Education as
trustee representing area three.
My professional background includes a decade of teaching eighth grade before serving as
the coordinator of the secondary teacher credential program and what is now Cal Poly
Humboldt, where I was a member of the School of Education teaching faculty for 14 years.
My children attended four schools in Humboldt County for their elementary education and two
of those schools were charter schools.
I reviewed the SBA proposal very carefully.
I concur with the findings from the Northern Humboldt School District and the County Office
of Education staff.
A particular concern is the quality and feasibility of the educational program and the lack of
professionally qualified teachers interested in working at the charter school.
Two years ago, I facilitated a countywide teacher shortage task force, which brought
together leaders from districts, the university, local tribal education leaders, and the County
Office of Education to seek solutions for our area.
The SBA proposal fails to address or maybe fully understand important staffing and credentialing
concerns facing our region.
Additionally, I was significantly concerned.
Thank you, Colleen.
Your time is up.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
My name is Tonya Trump.
I am the program manager for Career and College Resources employed by Humboldt County Office
of Education.
I consulted with Northern Humboldt Union High School District when they received a charter
petition from SBA claiming SBA would provide a CTE medical pathway program.
As I shared with council for the district, HCOE has been attempting to hire a qualified
health science and medical technology sector CTE teacher since May of 2021.
In June 2021, the position was posted in newspapers and other media such as adjoin and social
media.
This reached over 1,500 people with 49 engagements.
In September 2021, HCOE posted the position again and paid to boost it on social media.
Despite reaching nearly 1,900 people by October, we received only one applicant.
This applicant pulled their application after hearing the salary ranges in this area.
I am aware of two other large districts in this county who have been unable to recruit
CTE credentialed candidates for this pathway.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello.
It's Eric Premack with the Charter Schools Development Center.
I think the one thing that everybody agrees on today is that we don't have a definition
of the key term of use of discretion.
Under any definition of that term, however, the underlying statutes matter.
And in this case, the underlying statutes require the school districts to make specific
factual findings pertinent to the school in question.
And in this case, they failed to do that.
We also question the findings of the CDE on procedural matters.
We don't think they passed the Google test.
For these and other reasons, we would urge you to reverse the district's denial
and allow this school to move forward.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller, and hello.
Okay.
Thank you.
Good morning, state board members.
My name is Patty Campbell, and I'm the chair of the Samoa Beach Academy Board.
I'm a sixth generation Humboldt County native, a local business owner,
and a parent of three local high school graduates.
We are seeking to offer a research-based career technical education school,
which will directly prepare our students to go to work in the trades.
This aspect is extremely important to me as my family owns a lumber mill in Humboldt County,
and we've experienced firsthand the dwindling pool of qualified applicants for jobs.
With a public-private partnership opportunity in the trades like SBA will offer,
I know that local businesses like mine will immediately employ those graduates.
We have been on a very long road to seek approval of this charter,
which is proof of the commitment of this team.
We persevered after denials by the district and county and now ask you to reverse those denials
because the district and county did not follow the law.
Private citizens have to follow the law, and the same goes for government bodies.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits ending in 0866, you are live.
Please start your public comment now.
Good morning, honorable board members.
I'm Melanie Susavilla, a member of the district's petition review team.
I was in charge of special education for the district for five years and have seven years of
training and experience in the development of multi-tiered systems of support, or MTSS.
I consulted with our SOFA director and our regional CTE specialist and personally spent
more than 80 hours reviewing, investigating, and writing our findings based on the evidence.
Two key concerns were, one, SBA understaffed special education did not adequately budget
related services such as a single paraprofessional or provide a continuum of placement options.
I cannot emphasize enough how concerned I am for any students with IEPs attending SBA.
And two, the petition items related to MTSS are largely
summarized or copy and pasted text from the internet.
SBA has not outlined a development plan and does not have the experience to implement MTSS.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Larry Gonzalez and I've been a Humboldt County resident for over 12 years.
I came up here to go to Humboldt State University, graduated college, and upon graduating,
I couldn't find work, decent jobs, so I joined the trades.
Been there for eight years now and I wish I could have attended a high school such as
Beach Academy is proposing because I could have started a career in the trades a lot sooner,
probably be a lot farther and advanced in my career now than I would have been if I had
this opportunity.
I just believe that Humboldt County is growing and to continue growing, we have to grow the youth
and that's going to mean offering more career and technical education
because not everyone that graduates from a Humboldt County high school is going to go to college.
It's a reality.
We know it.
If you look at the college rates now, you know, they're not, it's not like 90%,
not everyone's going to college, so I just feel that college is not for everyone
and giving an opportunity to get technical skills in high school is just priceless
and I just really love that we have an opportunity to innovate
and get Humboldt County to be more competitive.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Oh, good morning, President Darling-Hammond and honorable members of the board.
I appreciate your service and thanks for having us here today.
I'm Roger McDonald, the superintendent of the Northern Humboldt Union High School District.
To address one issue raised in the appeal, Dave Law, the petitioner, did not request any specific
amount of time to present to our board on the day voted on the petition before you.
I suggested 10 minutes.
He agreed to it in an email, which is in evidence.
He could have easily asked for more time, which we have readily granted.
To dilute the charter petition, I created a district review team consisting of myself,
the district's fiscal director, the district's expert in special education,
multi-tiered systems of support, and counsel for the district.
This team consulted with the SELPA director, with our regional expert in CTE,
with the regional charter directors, and with other Humboldt County superintendents
who run CTE programs and who have engaged in dual enrollment with the two colleges
that were listed in the petition.
We also consulted with the following department leads in HWE, business services,
college and current personnel services.
It was these individuals' expertise that informed our recommendations
to deny the charter petition.
Thank you, caller.
There was no abuse of discretion.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
My name is Charles Barnhart.
I've been a resident of Humboldt County for 55 years.
I've been in the trades for 38 years.
I graduated from Eureka High School, and I wish I would have had an opportunity
like the Smoa Beach Academy is presenting here.
The trades have provided a tremendous living for my family.
We've pretty much wanted for nothing.
My son struggled in high school, and I barely got him through.
And then he went to a trade school in Arizona for audio engineering.
Flourished top five in his class.
He's a hands-on learner, which I know lots of kids are.
He's now an audio engineer in Universal Studios.
This type of program is much needed in Humboldt County,
and I support the Smoa Beach Academy.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you very much.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
My name is Mandy Hu, and I'm a staff attorney with California Teachers Association.
I'm responding to Smoa Beach Academy's definition of abusive discretion.
Minor procedural errors that do not affect the outcome of the district or county's
otherwise well-founded decisions to deny the petition should not be considered
abusive discretion.
To hold otherwise would be to flout the intention of AB 1505
that law significantly changed the role of the state board in the charter process
to ensure that the state board could not approve charter petitions denied
by district and counties unless there were significant issues
regarding the review and appeal process at the local level.
As Governor Brown recognized, this law restricts the state board's scope of review.
Under the new standards, local decision is intact unless it's an abusive discretion,
and minor procedural errors do not meet this high bar.
Under Smoa Beach's reading, if a petitioner submits a flagrantly unlawful charter petition,
for example, one that doesn't even describe a course of study,
but the district or county fails to give literally the same amount of time
to the petitioner as others at the hearing,
the state board would have to authorize a flagrantly unlawful petition.
Thank you, Coller.
The third result will not be the way the law is read.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Next, Coller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
This is Claire Crawford with In the Public Interest.
Despite assertions in previous comments, many new charter schools
have already been authorized with AB 1505 in place,
and the existence of the charter industry is not at stake today.
The petitioner's interpretation of the law is absurd.
When taken to its logical conclusion, a minor procedural error by a district
would require the state board to authorize any charter school
despite being denied by two local elected bodies
and regardless of how serious the findings.
For instance, the scandalous A3 founders could petition a district and a county,
and if the district staff spoke for one minute longer than the charter petitioners,
the SBE would be required to authorize the school.
This is clearly not the legislative intent.
CDE found no abuse of discretion.
Two elected bodies made findings supported by facts to deny this petition,
and the SBE should affirm their decision.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Next, Coller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
My name is Caroline Neuhaus-Wesley from Sephora Education Associates,
and I urge the board to reverse the determination
made by the governing boards of the district and the county
because there is clearly an abuse of discretion.
Anytime there is something that is procedurally unfair
or not proceeding with law, that is an unlawful act.
Therefore, it is an abuse of discretion.
You've heard a lot about staffing, food services, budget, and registrar,
and special ed.
All of those things are included in the budget.
I think there is a clear misunderstanding of the review of the charter petition
as food services can be found in line 4700, janitorial services 5502,
and registrar in 2400 of the budget.
Special education is a huge concern,
and to say that the school is demonstrably unlikely is unfair,
and I urge you to not make a precedent-setting case
which would cause a massive rejection of new charters.
Thank you.
Next, Coller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, State Board of Education members.
My name is Lorraine Richards, and I am a classroom teacher
representing the California Teachers Association.
A primary purpose of AB 1505 was to return control over charter school
authorizing to local school districts.
CTA supports the CDA staff recommendation to deny the appeal of Samoa Beach Academy.
As highlighted in the CSEA CTA letter,
minor procedural errors do not rise to the level of abuse of discretion,
and both the district and the county had strong reasons
to deny the petition that were well-founded.
Abuse of discretion is a very high standard
and meant to be extremely deferential to local decisions.
We urge the State Board of Education to affirm the school districts
and county's decision to deny the Samoa Beach Academy Charter School Petition.
Thank you.
Next, Coller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Coller, with the last four digits, 3599, you are live.
Please start your public comment now.
I'm sorry.
I think I'm on the wrong agenda item.
Okay.
Thank you.
Next, Coller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
This is Suzanne Kuya with the Charter Schools Development Center.
Thank you, members of the board, and thank you, Governor Brown.
CTE programs are needed, and per EDCO,
the establishment of charter schools should be encouraged.
So I'm confused why the intro slides only summarize the reasoning for the denial
and didn't give an equivalent summary of rebuttals.
The balance of the evidence must meet the legal standard,
unsound program, or demonstrably unlikely to succeed.
These are high legal bars.
Most of the denial findings, however, are speculative, not demonstrative.
Long list of findings of this nature are typical, but it doesn't mean they'll materialize.
Is there any specific substantive concern where the petitioners have been heard?
The intro slides showed that only the district staff got to respond to questions,
not the petitioners, and that is not minor.
We see an obvious abuse of discretion,
and the SBE does have this discretion to determine what to do in this case,
and we hope that they will give this school a chance to...
Thank you, Coller.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for item number 17.
All right.
I want to thank all of the public commenters.
This is a complicated determination, and we appreciate all of the input.
I am now going to close the public hearing at 10.55 a.m.
We'll begin board discussion, and I'd like to ask our liaisons,
Vice President Glover-Woods and Member Olken,
if they would like to make initial comments.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
Just some initial comments before we begin to engage in our discussion.
We did have opportunity to hear during this public hearing,
as well as through written documentation we received,
a lot of comments regarding the benefits of CTE programs,
and even the desire to see more of those offerings in the proposed area.
But I respectfully say to all of us that we are not
charged with the review of the petition itself.
What we are asked to do is to determine if there has been an abuse of discretion
on behalf of the district and county office,
and if so, decide accordingly from that point.
Just to again lift up the definition that we've been provided
regarding an abuse of discretion,
one of many things would need to have occurred.
So the definition we received was that an abuse of discretion
would be that the actions of the district and county office
were either arbitrary, capricious, lacking in evidentiary support,
unlawful, or procedurally unfair.
So again, we've got a lot of information.
This is a very important conversation and discussion to have,
but I just encourage us to anchor ourselves
with what we have been charged to do as a board,
which is to decide if there has been abuse of discretion
on behalf of the district and county office,
which has resulted in a denial of the charter petition.
Thank you, Member Glever Woods for that start,
and certainly thank you to everyone who presented today,
both formally and through public comment.
This is a very meaty, complicated, and new thing for us to be deciding upon,
and so I appreciate the reminder of what the new rules are and what our role is.
I myself, as I was listening to the presentations and the public comment,
spent most of the time trying to disentangle what felt like,
which parts of what we were hearing were comments on the merits of the charter versus
comments on the process that has happened thus far,
because my understanding is we're looking at process,
rather than at the...we're not redesigning whether this charter school is...whether it
has merit as a school or not. That's not our role today,
and so I spent most of the time trying to disentangle the comments myself,
so I look forward to hearing our deliberation as we take this on. Thank you.
Thank you. We're now open for board discussion.
If anyone has comments or questions that they would like to raise.
Yes, Vice President Glever Woods.
I did have a clarifying question, and I'm not quite sure who should respond to it.
As it relates to the public hearing and the difference in time, my question is,
were the petitioners denied a request to present for more time after seeing that the district
presented for longer than the time that had been requested by the petitioners,
because my understanding is the petitioners requested 10 minutes and presented for 11,
then the district presented afterwards. Then seeing the difference in time,
did the petitioners ask for more time, and if they did, were they denied that request?
Yes. Stephanie, are you available to answer that question?
Yes, I am. So the petitioners, as we understand it, and at the district level we did watch the video,
did not request more time. They were given, well, they were asked how much time they needed. They
had said 10 minutes. That is illustrated in emails that are attached to the documentary record.
At the actual hearing, they gave 11 minutes. As you noted, Member Glever Woods, they were not
asked to stop their presentation, nor did we see them request more time during the hearing.
Any other questions or comments? Member Lewis?
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond, and thank you, Vice President Glever Woods, and for your
guidance in directing us to really stay focused on what our charge is here today and not try to
comment on the merits of the actual petition. So I just want to just be clear about the response
from the CDE response, the district, and the county's response to the allegations. I just
want to make sure that I heard things correctly and that I have it accurately. You've already
asked the President, excuse me, Vice President Glever Woods already asked the question, clarifying
question about the time. And the second allegation of the petitioners was that
they did not get the opportunity, the Board didn't have the opportunity to receive their
written response to the county and the district's findings. And I just want to make sure that I
heard correctly that the SBA actually directly emailed their responses to the Board, and that's
why their responses were not included with the Board agenda along with staff responses. Is that
correct? I'm not sure who I'm asking that one of the CDE staff. I think Stephanie is the person
we're asking at this moment if she can provide that answer. So there is no requirement in Ed
Code for the district to post the petitioner's response to their findings. There is a requirement
Ed Code that the district post their findings 15 days before the public hearing to decide
on the petition. But there is no requirement that the district post the charter's responses.
From what I understand, and we can certainly ask them directly, but from what I understand from
the documentary record and from the district, I believe or the county attorney's response earlier
that the response from the charter petitioners was directly emailed to every Board member prior
to the hearing. So they did have the opportunity to review that response.
That is what we just heard. Okay. Okay. Thank you. And also there was no, in the petitioner's
allegation about they should not have been required to obtain new signatures. And I believe what I
heard was that wasn't a requirement. It was merely the Board and the county because they had contacted
the teacher, the four teachers who were listed in the petition. And there was no continued interest
with them going, being a part of the academy. And they were merely asking for more, but there
wasn't a requirement made to submit more. That affected the judgment of the county or the
district. That wasn't a procedural violation. Just clarification. Just making sure I'm
reading that correctly, if I'm asking it correctly. So I think that it was
not clear in the documentary record. If you notice in our A-1, we did not find
the sufficient findings within the documentary record. I believe the county did answer that
question during their testimony today. And we can certainly go back to them if they would like to
answer that. But it seemed to be a real matter of best practice for the county in reaching out to
those teacher signature folks to find out if they were still interested, which is not prohibited
by Ed Code, certainly. Member Lewis, is that responsive to your question?
It is responsive. And I really want to stay focused on whether or not it was abuse of discretion
based on those categories that were described in the definition. So I believe it was answered
sufficiently for my clarification. Thank you. I'm sorry, President Hammond. I would remind
that the abuse of discretion standard really applies to the decision to deny and not the
individual procedural errors that have been discussed here today. Your decision
to find an abuse of discretion must be on the totality of the decision to deny.
Thank you. Okay. Member Patio-Bronson and then Member Olken.
So I want to start by thanking Vice President Glover-Wood for the framing and the reminder of
sort of what the changed standard of review, the more limited standard of review that we're
looking at. And also for folks who are watching that noticing that it is quite a different
standard review than what we have undertaken before. I remember when 1505 was enacted and
I think it was described as the first major overhaul to the charter school law since its
inception and laws have consequences. I think the abuse of discretion standard is quite clear
that it is a more limited review. So the conversation on the merits is a much more
circumscribed form of review that we're undertaking. And I think CDE analysis has been, I think,
quite compelling around why on the merits there hasn't been an abuse of discretion.
The procedural pieces, I think, and it was very helpful just to hear the totality of the
circumstances description that was just provided. I did just want to ask around the piece on the
transcript. I appreciate the clarification as to the time differential that was raised and
certainly I don't think equal time would mean leaving, for example, a 30-minute timer
going just because the other side had presented for 30 minutes and not having asked for additional
time having been given as much time as the petitioner wanted to provide I think is actually
a pretty generous version of how the time could be allotted. I did want to just confirm that
there's nothing in Ed code that prohibits, however, a video transcript as being the official
record. Stephanie, can you respond to that? I can. There is not anything in Ed code and I'm
sure Judy Sias can weigh in if this is not correct, but there is nothing in Ed code that
prohibits a video being sent or being used as the transcript. I believe that the Ed code states
just transcript. It doesn't even state written transcript. For now, CDE has made the decision
that a video transcript or a video is sufficient for a transcript. We do ask that there be timing
on the video so that it can be cited to, but you are correct that Ed code does not prohibit a video.
Judy, did you want to add anything?
Yes, Stephanie is correct. Ed code does not prohibit a video transcript and there are other
agencies that accept video transcript in these types of hearings. If the goal of the transcript
is to allow the petitioners to have a record of what has occurred, the video with the time stamps
seem to achieve the same result. Thank you. Thank you. Member Olken?
Thank you. First, as we were talking about time and the differential on amount of time for
presentations, one thing I've noted over the last couple of days is our very clear each side gets 12
minutes. I don't have any indication that that's a requirement in any way
of law. It's an interesting way of looking at what equal time looks like. I want to put that out
there. The second thing is as somebody who leads to charter schools, I think
as I was listening to and reading through the concerns about the viability of Samoa Beach Academy,
there were pieces where I thought to myself, in my world, I might very well be the person
heating lunch because if the choice is I'm going to put money into the classroom or I'm going to
put money into the heating of lunches, I guarantee you I'm putting money in the classroom and I am
heating lunches up. There were quite a few examples of that in the concerns and in the
reasons that either the budget or the academic program were deemed unsound where I thought
through my lens, I'm not sure about that, or I disagree. That said, I don't believe
that that's the standard by which we're supposed to be deciding today.
I appreciated former Governor Brown's comments about that being frustrating.
I appreciated him calling in to that effect. I just feel like it's important to put these
things out here. That leads me to the second part, which is AB 1505 was a long and
collaborative and complicated process to get it passed. I think in the charter school world,
there was a sense that in exchange for what was definitely some dialing back of
the onus for denial, putting more responsibility on charter schools, put it that way, there were
some procedural safeguards enacted that felt important because we see in schools all the time
the importance of procedural safeguards. We see the importance of procedural safeguards for
students going through the IEP process or through the disciplinary process. These things matter.
I was wondering if we could re-hear from the department why they believe that the
process wasn't followed entirely, but that they didn't raise to the level of
abusive discretion. I was wondering if we could re-hear those because that feels like a really
key point to me in terms of being able to make a decision.
Thank you. I think we want to ask Stephanie and perhaps Judy to come back to the discussion.
Thank you. I think we want to ask Stephanie and perhaps Judy to respond to that.
Thank you. I'm actually standing here with CDE's chief counsel, Amy Holloway,
who would like to respond. Thank you.
I can't see over the podium. Good morning, Amy Holloway. I am now the deputy
over the charter schools division. Normally when we were in person you'd see me at a desk and
avoiding public comment. I feel compelled in this instance to give you some information,
in particular in response to member Olken's comments, which are well taken. I think that
we need to make sure that the record is clear that what 47605 requires is equivalent time and
procedure. It does not require equal, so equivalent should mean that it feels fair on the record
about whether each side had appropriate and adequate opportunity to be heard. We haven't
heard from SBA that they did not feel that they didn't have sufficient time or that they didn't
ask for additional time. What they said was we needed 10 minutes, so the district and the county
in this instance should have been limited to 10 minutes and that the questions that the board
members had for the county should have been limited to the same number of questions or the
same amount of time for SBA. As decision makers, think about how you would feel if your discretion
were limited that you had to ask each side the same number or types of questions. Now there may
be that SBA felt that if it had opportunities to answer questions it could have presented additional
information, but the record does not require, the statute does not require that the board's exercise
of discretion in asking each side the same number of questions or have the same issues for each side.
I also appreciate the member Olkins comments about she did not agree in some cases and I think that's
going to be a very hard place for you all to be as well as you know in reviewing the decisions,
but courts have made clear that in an abuse of discretion standard you don't get to substitute
your judgment for that of the trial or fact or the parties that heard that and in fact many of
the lawsuits that we see against the state are from folks saying we think you should have operated
this program differently, not that the law required it but we think you should have done something,
you should have exercised your discretion differently. So I think member Olkins comments
are helpful to locals about how they should be looking at these petitions when they come before
them and it may be a good signal to the legislature that there is some needed
amendments to the statute. I don't know but I take her comments to heart and also wanted
to mention that the staff around this item worked extremely hard, the charter school staff, legal
staff to make sure that they were implementing the statute as written in spite of its areas where
clarity would be of benefit. And lastly with regard to the procedural safeguards,
we take each case as it's presented so in another case the equivalent time might be more dramatic,
it might have been imposed to limit the charter schools or the district or the county's ability
to present the information that they felt that the board needed to make their decisions. That's
not necessarily in the record, it's not in the record as presented to you today. And lastly with
regard to the transcript, if an issue was raised about the manner in which the hearing was held
and the transcript would demonstrate that and a charter petitioner is inhibited or barred in their
ability to present that information, then this board could find that the failure to have a
transcript was something that could be viewed against the local decision and you could overturn
that. But that's not the case here again and the transcript itself does not constitute
the decision that was before the local board. It documents it and the process that they use,
so I don't want to minimize its importance. The statute does not require the districts to create,
develop or maintain a transcript. It says the districts and the county shall produce a written
record including transcripts and I know that's a point that's a little vague but we don't impose
obligations on local districts, local LA's without express statutory authority for that. So thank you.
And just to clarify, there was a video which is serving as the transcript, is that correct?
Yes, from the district.
Thank you. Are there other questions or comments?
Are there other questions or comments?
All right, I think if there are not additional questions or comments, we're probably ready for
a motion and I just would like to say as we're thinking about the motion, just to reinforce
that this is a complicated situation. We're asked to make a procedural determination not
based on the merits of the petition. I shared your view, Member Olken, that sometimes the standard
that was applied was a standard of how would we do it in a traditional setting, not necessarily how
might an innovative school approach particular elements of the program. So I think it's important
for us just to, as Amy said, to be clear that that's not an expectation that we're holding of
the review of charges but Governor Brown was right that the decision we make is by legislative
requirement one that is really only about the procedural elements of this, not the merits
of the petition itself. We're doing our due diligence and implementing the statute to the
best of our ability and unless we're finding that, for example, in the cases that Member
Olken raised that the decision was, quote, entirely lacking in evidentiary support,
which is the standard that we've been given, we will not be substituting our judgment for the
judgment of the people who reviewed the petition. I do appreciate all the public comments and letters
we received on the issue. There's a heightened level of attention surrounding the action to
be taken today because this is the first abuse of discretion appeal implementing AB 1505.
I understand because it's a new process there's been a significant shift in the board's role and
authority. There may be a temptation for folks to speculate about future board actions based
solely on this single appeal because it is the first one in line and I do want to provide a
caution about reading too much into today's decision should we move to approve the
department's recommendation. Both the department and the board are taking a new charge very
seriously. The analysis and the board's decision are based on this specific administrative record
before us, the totality of the circumstances in this particular appeal. We have received a
thorough analysis, I thank the CDE staff for that, and in the future each petition and each
administrative record will receive the same level of review and analysis and the board will make a
decision based on the totality of the particular circumstances involved. I don't want to discuss
hypotheticals but if we move to approve the department's recommendation the action today
should not be misconstrued as sending a message that we're not concerned about procedural issues
or evidentiary issues or that those issues might never serve as the basis for a determination
that there has been an abuse of discretion. So with that framing I'd like to see if we have
someone who'd like to make a motion on this decision. Member Glover Woods.
Thank you President Darling-Hammond for that framing. So with that being said I do move that
we affirm the CDE recommendation and affirm the decision to deny the SBA charter petition
that was made by the district and the county office. And do I have a second for that motion?
I second it. Thank you very much. Any further discussion of the motion?
Member Glover Woods your hand is okay it's going down. Seeing no other discussion I would ask
Brooks to call the roll for the vote. Member Rodriguez.
Aye. Member Petillo-Brownson. Yes. Member Orozco-Gonzalez. Yes. Member Olken.
Yes. Member McQuillan. Aye. Member Lewis. Yes. Vice President Glover Woods.
Yes. Member Escobedo. Yes. President Darling-Hammond. Yes. Member Bonacca. Aye. Motion carries.
Thank you and we'll now take a 15 minute break and return at 1140.
All right welcome back everyone. Board members we need to re-establish the quorum so Brooks is
going to call the roll. Member Rodriguez. Yes. Member Petillo-Brownson. Yes. Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Yes. Member Olken. Yes. Member McQuillan. Yes. Member Lewis. Yes. Vice President Glover Woods.
Yes. Member Lewis. Yes. Vice President Glover Woods. Yes. Member Escobedo. Yes. President Darling-Hammond.
Yes. Member Bonacca. Yes. Everyone's present we have a quorum.
All right so we're up to item 8018 which is the time community school consider issuing a notice
of violation pursuant to California education code 47607G and this item will be presented by
Stephanie. Stephanie please begin. Thank you. So item number 18 consideration of the issuance
of a notice of violation to time community school pursuant to California education code section
47607G. A little background on time. The appeal to establish TCS was heard by the California
State Board of Education at its July 9th 2020 meeting. At this meeting the CDE recommended
that the SBE deny the TCS petition. At its June 9th 2020 meeting the advisory commission on charter
schools did not agree with CDE's recommendation to deny the school and instead voted to approve
the TCS petition with a delay in opening for one year. The motion passed by a vote of seven to two.
The SBE voted to approve the charter petition to establish time for a term of five years effective
July 1 2020 with a delay in opening and starting instruction in the 21-22 school year. That motion
passed by 10 votes. At the same meeting this SBE delegated delegated oversight of time charter
school to the Los Angeles County Board of Education pursuant to former ed code section 47605K1.
The Los Angeles County Board of Education delegated monitoring and oversight of TCS
to the Los Angeles County Office of Education.
Since March 2022 CDE and SBE staff have been in communication with LACO about LACO's concerns
regarding the sustainability of time charter school. Due to the nature of the concerns a
recommendation to the state board of ed regarding the issuance of a notice of violation to TCS was
discussed. At that time LACO expressed their desire to continue collaborating and providing
guidance to TCS in the hopes of bringing the school into compliance and into a more stable
fiscal position. The CDE and LACO believe that there is substantial evidence that TCS
engaged in fiscal mismanagement failed to meet or pursue any of the pupil outcomes identified
in the charter petition and committed a material violation of the conditions standards or procedures
set forth in the charter petition. For the aforementioned reason the CDE recommends that
the SBE consider issuing a notice of violation to time charter school pursuant to ed code section
47607G. And so now President Darling-Hammond I am going to hand over the bulk of the presentation
to the Los Angeles County Office of Education Mr. Indra Chikarali who is the Director II of
the charter school's office for LACO and as they have been conducting the oversight of time they will
provide the board with the details of why we are asking the board to issue a notice of violation.
Mr. Chikarali.
Great thank you so much.
There you go and that is that screen up for everybody to see?
Yes.
All right thank you.
Good morning board members as you know Time Community School began instruction in July of 2021
within the boundaries of the Montebello Unified School District. In its first year of operation
Time planned to enroll 260 students in grades 9 and 10. Prior to opening the school submitted
evidence of enrollment for 263 students. Despite this evidence the school opened with only 27
students and eventually enrolled a total of just 41 students by October failing to enroll any
additional students throughout the school year. Here you have the school's mission and operating
entity presented to you on the screen in front of you.
On the screen in front of you.
Give you a moment to read that.
Since Time's authorization LACO has taken many steps to support time including seven site visits
by LACO staff including the charter school office facilities unit and Los Angeles County SELPA.
Two comprehensive meetings with the executive director and members of the governing board
monthly fiscal monitoring bi-weekly zoom meetings with all authorized county charter schools
and regular meetings calls and emails with a LACO assigned coordinator. Unfortunately time has been
unwilling to implement much of the guidance offered by LACO staff based on LACO's extensive
experience with new charter schools. Therefore despite this widespread support LACO staff were
prompted to send out two notifications of concern delivered to the time board on January 26th
and June 28th of 2022. The following items were listed in the January 26th notice of concern.
Time failed to demonstrate financial viability in the current and subsequent fiscal years
due to its enrollment shortfall, deficit spending, potential cash def deficiencies,
reliance on debts, and a negative ending net position for the 2021-22 fiscal year.
Time failed to demonstrate the implementation of ELD standards for long-term English learners
as required by federal and state law. This population represents almost half the school's
student body. Time failed to implement teacher credentialing requirements and lastly at the time
of the LACO fall oversight visit time had not cured all required corrections from an initial
facility inspection conducted on May 26, 2021. Time did however work with the Montebello Unified
School District to eventually cure these remaining corrections.
As previously mentioned, LACO sent time a second notice of concern on June 28th based on the issues
listed here. Each concern will be detailed in the slides to follow.
First, both LACO and CDE staff found that the time budget and multi-year projections are based
on unrealistic enrollment projections. In addition, time is fiscally insolvent for the
current fiscal year and also in the subsequent two fiscal years due to unrealistic projections.
This table before you here illustrates time's unrealistic enrollment in ADA projections
from its PENSEC report to fiscal year 2023-24. The proposed ADA increase in 2022-23
represents 185% increase from the 2021-22 enrollment. In addition, there is another
50% increase in 2023-24 for a two-year total increase of 120 ADA or a 327% increase from 2021-22.
This table here illustrates projected fiscal insolvency and includes the school's financial data
submitted for fiscal year 2021-22 operation, including the budget, first and second interims
and actuals through May 31, 2022. Time ended May 31, 2022 with a structural deficit of negative
$321,464 and an ending net position of negative $211,793. In addition,
time's reserves for economic uncertainties is a negative 21.7%.
This slide illustrates the concerns of debt accumulation and cash flow projections.
As of May 31, 2022, time has a fund balance of negative $211,794, notes payable of $211,348
due to the executive director and a loan owed to the California School of Finance Authority
for $100,000. Also, as of May 31, 2022, time has a cash balance of $8,105 or three days of operating
cash. For fiscal year 2022-23, the school plans to sell current and future receivables and access
a California School of Finance Authority revolving loan in the amount of $150,000.
Cash flow projections reflect negative cash balances for six out of 12 months in 2022-23.
Due to cash deficiencies and reliance on borrowing, time may not be able to meet
its obligations, including payroll expenses and related benefits.
I would now like to hand the presentation over to my colleague, Dr. Daryl Brown, coordinator
three with the Los Angeles County Office of Education to review student academic outcomes.
Thank you, Indra. As the school has struggled to meet its financial obligations,
it has also struggled to meet the academic obligations to its students.
Time submitted an annual report to LACO that included NWEA benchmark data for the 21-22 school
year. However, no students took all three assessments given in the fall, winter, and spring
for language usage, and only 8% of students took two out of three tests for language usage.
Benchmark participation rates in all academic areas were significantly below
the 95% threshold established by the SBE for verifiable student data.
The majority of students, two-thirds, did not meet the expected growth metric that
would be required for renewal. This lack of student data directly impacts LACO's ability
to assess student learning and causes concern regarding the school's process for assessing
students as well as how instructional decisions are being made. On June 28,
Time submitted a revised version of the annual report based on additional data requested by LACO.
This updated report did not change the findings related to the school failing to report benchmark
data for all students and low student participation. In addition, the report did not include an
analysis of NWEA conditional growth index data as also requested by LACO. Troublingly,
the report incorrectly compares CASP proficiency data from Montebello Unified School District
to Time's NWEA growth data. Time's growth data is based on NWEA assessments which are in no way
designed to be comparable to CASP proficiency data. Time's continued attempt to compare these
incongruous metrics again causes concern over Time's ability to analyze their data.
With regard to operations, the school facility that Time occupied in 21-22 did not align with
the facility design included in the charter petition. The petition includes an illustration
of an open classroom space with border-free classrooms and a central learning hub designed
to support the unique Time community school's learning model. Despite discussions regarding
how accommodations and modifications might be made for the school to be more reflective
of the learning model described in the petition, Time continued to reflect a traditional standard
program throughout the 21-22 school year. In regards to staffing, the 22-23 proposed staffing
list does not include a full-time counselor. The originally approved petition included one counselor
in year one, adding an additional counselor in years two and three. During the 21-22 school year,
Time did hire a counselor. However, after staff turnover in the fall, the counseling position was
left vacant. The impact was immediate as the school admitted that the loss of the counselor
early in the school year caused participation errors with benchmark testing. Dr. Ramirez,
the Time executive director, has stated that he will continue to assume counseling responsibilities.
However, he does not hold a counseling credential and has cited experience with
college admissions and scheduling only. In addition to academic support, a counselor plays a significant
role in the social and emotional lives of students, particularly during this time where we have seen
increases in the social and emotional needs of students resulting from the COVID-19 pandemic
and traumatic experiences outside of school. Failure to include this critical staff position
calls into question Time's ability to adequately serve the needs of its students.
Finally, there are some additional concerns for the board to take into account.
Time has submitted a material revision to change locations and modify the school calendar for the
upcoming school year. It is unclear how and when the school will make necessary upgrades to the
proposed private location. The material revision includes an affidavit which states that Time will
complete the required facilities fixes contingent upon LACO providing the school a letter of good
standing for the sale of receivables. LACO has previously met with members of the Time board
and the executive director and informed them that a letter of good standing would not be issued.
Time is also awaiting an accreditation term based on its initial WASP visit in April of 2022.
Lastly, there is a concern regarding the organizational guidance provided by the
Time board in light of the previously mentioned fiscal academic and instructional program concerns.
Thank you, Dr. Brown. In summary, while there has been some extenuating circumstances such as the
COVID pandemic, that does not change the fact that despite widespread guidance and support,
Time has been unable to demonstrate fiscal sustainability, program adherence,
or positive student outcomes. Thank you so much and I will now hand the presentation back to CDE staff.
Thank you, LACO staff for the presentation. So in conclusion, the CDE and LACO believe that there
is substantial evidence that TCS engaged in fiscal mismanagement failed to meet or pursue any of the
people outcomes identified in the charter petition and committed a material violation of the condition
standards or procedures set forth in the charter petition. The CDE recommends that the SBE
consider issuing a notice of violation to TCS and as stated in the draft notice of violation
that is included in your item, TCS does have until July 20th to respond to the notice of violation.
And that ends our presentation. All right, do you want to put up the public comment slide?
So we will now open the phone line for public comment. Members of the public wishing to provide
comment on the item may do so by calling the telephone number and using the access code
provided on the slide that is shown now. While we're waiting for members of the public to queue up
for comment, I want to ask Vice President Glover-Woods and Member Olken if they have any initial comments,
and then if we have any clarifying questions, we'll be happy to answer them.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. Just to help to frame what we will be deciding in this
particular item, again, we've received a lot of information regarding the concern, as well as
information we've received from the SBE. We've received a lot of information from the SBE
as well as information we've received from the charter itself. The action that we would be looking
at today would be to issue a notice of violation. It's not a revocation, but a notice of violation
to provide opportunity in a formal manner for the charter to respond to some of the concerns
that have been brought forward. Thank you. Member Olken?
I don't have anything to add at this time. Thank you.
Thank you. In terms of clarifying questions, I'm going to ask one and then invite others if they
have clarifying questions as well. One of the first points on the list of concerns is fiscal
mismanagement, and I saw plenty of evidence of fiscal instability and concern.
I don't know that I understood what the mismanagement
point was, and maybe you could clarify that for us.
Thank you, President Hammond. Thank you for the question. I'm happy to answer that.
We really saw fiscal mismanagement for time as three big items. One, their lack of a strategic
plan to get out of debt. Two, their failure to prioritize actions to adhere to the PCSGP
grant requirements and to pursue other grant opportunities. And then finally,
their failure to adjust their expenditures to reflect the actual budget.
Thank you. Any other clarifying questions?
All right. With that, we will go to public comment if there are some.
So, yes, we have five callers in the queue. I will open up the phone line now.
Good afternoon. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi. I hope it's me that's talking. Mark Scott is my name. I'm a former
Los Angeles County Office of Education employee. We did about 20 years there
in crisis intervention. My comment is to a pretty small window, but I'll try to describe
it as quickly as possible. I just saw an incredible effort in community support and culture,
working with the facilities that were limited in opportunity. I won't say there was hostility,
but certainly there was difficulty in accessing the facilities. But I still saw a lot of progress
in using the facility for everything from open area workshops in the auditorium to open area labs
in the science lab. But what I was most impressed with was their trauma mitigation.
And from my perspective, working in MTSS and PBIS, seeing that they had reduced office referrals,
that resulted more in access to curriculum, which is my perspective.
Thank you, caller. Your time is up. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, State Board of Education members. My name is Lorraine Richards,
and I am a classroom teacher representing California Teacher Association. CTA supports
the CDE's recommendation that the State Board of Education consider issuing a notice of violation
to time community schools. As outlined in the item, time has committed the following,
fiscal mismanagement, failure to meet or pursue any of the pupil outcomes identified in the
charter petition, and violation of several conditions, standards, or procedures set forth
in the charter petition. These issues were clearly predicted by the CDE during the July
2020 hearing for time, and now it is time for the State Board of Education to take action by issuing
the notice of violation. Thank you very much.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Lisa Kimada from the Montevallo Teachers Association.
I am in support of a violation notice going to time charter because of the local and county
denials showing strong indicators that the students are being compromised regarding their safety,
their security, and their academic stability. There is no counselor, there is no accreditation,
and there is insufficient assessment data. There is, however, clear fiscal responsibility.
During this climate in America, safety is paramount, and time charter shows no indication
of doing anything to support the security and safety of students. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning. My name is Jessica Zwaal, and I work at Montevallo High School,
and I'm here as a member of the Montevallo Teachers Association.
Speaking in favor of the notice of violation to the time community charter item 18,
the school should have never been approved after it was denied by the Montevallo Unified
School Board and the Los Angeles County Office of Education. This was a disservice to students
at both time charter and Montevallo High. Time charter lacked participation in benchmark
assessments, has no accreditation, and did not provide counselors. Time charter provided
broken promises to its students and families. Observations alone revealed attendance was an
issue at time charter. Montevallo High School provided multiple classrooms to time charter,
and it barely had enrollment to host a partial class. Time community has had trouble managing
student behavior. Students disrupted educational services at Montevallo High School because they
tried to integrate themselves into the Montevallo High School classrooms because they wanted to be
part of the traditional high school and not the charter. Time charter destroyed substantial
equipment in the computer lab, paid for by the district, and they only used that they did not
notify anyone. Thank you. Your time is up. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Well, my name is Lamar Brown, the president of Time Community Schools. I'm here today to provide
assurance that SBE is asking for in regards to our financial statement capacity. The TCS
Board conducts every meeting committed to transparency, thoughtfulness, integrity,
and a desire to look out for the interests of all stakeholders. As the president, it's an honor to
work with TCS, and no one understands the fiscal responsibility that has been bestowed upon us
within the last past school year. I have been challenging the board, the executive director,
and the TCS team revigilant in examining our finances throughout the year. We made a tough
decision to cut expenditures to ensure our academic program could continue to operate
successfully. We have utilized best practices and captain of resources that charter schools
regularly use, especially startups. Currently, our enrollment has nearly doubled what it was last
year, and we have students each day. We have the students and the budget to be valuable and
sustainable. Please do not move forward with this notice because TCS has provided thewill provide
the evidence, the tenacity and commitment to operate what we would believe to be the best
school in the state of California. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond and esteemed board members. My name is Gina Plait
from the California Charter Schools Association. The state board unanimously approved this school
back in 2020 as the board saw the value that it was bringing to this local community.
And then while we thought we knew what the impacts of the pandemic were, the truth is nobody
could have predicted the many challenges that came up when trying to open a school during the
pandemic and in a Prop 39 facility. The challenges that you have read about in your materials,
including the info included in recent legal action, resulted in fewer enrollments than projected,
and this is not fiscal mismanagement and should not be characterized as such.
Now, however, the school is in its own facility and not facing the many burdens they face
previously. School starts on August 17th, and if you issue this notice, you will only impede
the momentum that the school has finally generated. We respectfully request that you not issue the
notice of violation. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller, you are live. Please state your name and affiliation.
Hi, my name is Brandi Price. I'm the vice president of the TCS board. TCS opened its doors
to students in July 2021, and children who were not thriving in traditional schools found their
way to us. The incoming ninth grade class GPA was 1.71, and for 10th grade it was 1.2. The innovative
time learning model was created for all students, and especially for those who have not experienced
success in school often or yet. The TCS ninth grade semester two class GPA was 2.77, and for
10th grade 2.56, grades indicate something beyond academic achievement, engagement.
Our students became invested in school, and it showed anyone fortunate enough to visit the campus
side. Next year, TCS, this upcoming school year, TCS will have its own facility of significant
development. The proposition 39 facility did not appeal to families, and consequently we lost
enrollment. Notably, our enrollment has already nearly doubled. This year we had challenges,
but also so many successes. Nearly 50 percent of our students had GPAs of 1.0 or below,
nearly before joining us. Thank you, Coller, your time is up.
Thank you, Coller. That concludes public comment for item number 18.
All right, thank you very much. I want to allow three minutes of time for Dr. Gabriel
Ramirez, the school's leader, to address the board.
Hello, can you hear me? Yes. Great, thank you. Good morning, President Darlene Hammond and SBE
board members. My name is Dr. Gabriel Ramirez, and I am the executive director and founder of
Time Community Schools. Thank you for the opportunity to speak today, although I wish
the invitation was rooted in celebrating the many successes of time. Like our many school-wide
academic improvements, the growth of our student leaders, development of partnerships,
and the many stories of individual student transformations. Also, I'd like to share that
we were just informed that we will be moving on to the final round for membership to the League of
Innovative Schools, a national network that connects and supports the most forward-thinking
leaders in education, started by the Department of Education under President Obama. Today I will
provide you with the facts and assurance needed to dismiss this notice of violation. The first
finding attempts to connect fiscal mismanagement to low enrollment. This is a false equivalent.
While TCS did not meet first-year projections due to the global pandemic and the challenging
relationship we had with our local district, time has worked diligently to increase our enrollment,
and currently TCS has 72 fully registered students with another 16 in process of completing
registration, a total of 88 families. TCS has essentially increased its enrollment by over 100%.
Also, TCS has over 200 families who have expressed interest in our school, so we continue to recruit
and our numbers will increase. TCS has provided LACO the names of our registered families, which
is the evidence needed to demonstrate that our projections are not unrealistic. In order to give
more assurance, we have reworked our budget at 85 students, and time is financially viable and is
able to meet its reserve requirements. Next, the finding alleges that time did not meet
pupil outcomes identified in the charter petition. To clarify, time's petition identifies pupil
outcomes in relation to state assessments, and time did not assess students because we currently
do not have an 11th grade class to provide any data. In regards to NWEA benchmarks, time has
provided all data to the LACO, including all other academic data requested. TCS looks forward to
sharing student state assessment scores once we have an 11th grade class to establish a baseline
and then to compare to future classes. We have pursued the pupil outcomes using the NWEA assessment
as a benchmark. The third finding provides that time committed a mature revision in relation to
our charter petition specific to facilities. In our charter petition, we described our ideal of
what we would like our school to someday look like. However, in our charter petition, we also
acknowledged that this might not be possible due to facility requirements and our growth.
TCS has made every effort to incorporate the furniture, the physical design, and use of
collaborative procedures to transform every classroom into a tool to aid in learning and
meet our vision, despite the constraints of Prop 39. On July 29, 2020, the SBE approved
time's charter position because the SBE believed in our innovation and capacity. Time has made
extraordinary progress and has had a profound impact on our community. We have addressed all
concerns, financial and academic, and have demonstrated that we are viable and capable.
Thank you. I'm asking today that the board not move forward with the notice of violation.
Thank you. Thank you.
All right. Thank you very much. We are open for board discussion.
And I wonder if I could ask Stephanie to put up the motion as it is currently framed.
Member Escobedo and then Vice President Glover Woods.
Yeah. I have a question on the pupil outcomes in the sense of utilizing benchmarks typically to
um judge charters. Is that consistent? Because my understanding of benchmarks are used to
really plan for future instruction and kind of reflect on the next quarter or semester.
I'm just curious on that area and how it's being used or applied in this case.
Do you, I'm not sure I completely understand your question. Are you directing that to
to Director Ramirez?
Yes. Yes. Or in general with CDE is I'm just curious why they found substantial evidence
in that area number two.
Given that we don't yet have state tests available.
Exactly. I think I just find it premature.
Sure. May I respond?
Sure. Yes. Well, I would agree with you.
Board member Escobedo, I would say that you're correct. If you look at what's listed on the
screen, it says identified in the charter petition, which benchmarks are not. Further,
according to the LACO MOU, when they do refer to internal benchmarks, there's just a reference
to submit those, which we did. And there is no timeline or deadline listed in the LACO MOU.
In speaking to LACO at the time, they asked for it. They specifically, when we spoke to
our coordinator and the initial discussion that was had was that we were supposed to submit,
they asked us to submit it when we could, but that by July that they would like to have that.
And then the timeframes changed very quickly. But ultimately, schools are supposed to be
charged according to the dashboard year to year, not within one school year. So this finding to me
just seems to be not in line with what was meant to happen in terms of charter schools.
I'd like to respond to that a little bit.
Hang on a second. Wait a minute. I'll get to you if we complete this part. Okay.
Director Rivera, did you finish your statement?
Yes.
It seems like you're interrupted.
Sorry. Yes, unless there's any other further questions to clarify.
Okay. So, Mr. Ciccarelli, go ahead and offer your view.
Yes. So currently, you know, when we're looking at charter schools, we're always looking towards
renewal. And currently under education code, one of those standards for renewal is showing
year over year academic progress for all students. And the state has issued a list,
CDE has issued a list of what is considered verifiable data and what are the metrics to be used
for that piece of evidence. And NWEA CGI is one of the metrics that is identified. So that is
something we ask all of our charter schools to have one of those identified verifiable data pieces
that they are tracking in order for them to be able to make their argument for renewal.
And so when we look at those scores, one, you know, it was difficult because we didn't always get,
we didn't get the actual CGI, which is the approved metric by the state. But even so,
looking at that NWEA data, we certainly did not see a majority of students that were meeting that
standard of year over year growth.
We're talking about a charter that's only been around for a year. So how could we have year over
year growth? No, it's the, that's the point of the verifiable data piece. That's the point of NWEA
is that it's standardized so that you can do your pre-test and your post-test and you can actually
see if there was an expected growth for that time, specific time period. So we can see sort of that,
you know, if it's two, if it's, excuse me, fall to spring or winter to spring, that particular
growth metric is standardized for that particular time period. And you can determine whether the
students actually met their expected growth or not. And that's what we looked at and saw that
majority of students did not meet their expected growth for that specific-
But you did have test scores for them. So the assessment was conducted.
I'm going to move on to a member Glover Woods and member Olfin who have their hands up. Thank you.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. Was that for me to go?
Yes, please.
Thank you very much. Director Ramirez, thank you so much for sharing as you have with us. And as
was indicated, the board, the State Board of Education did approve this charter even though
it was recommended not to. So I think that shows kind of a vote in confidence of the merits of the
charter petition at the time when it was decided to move forward. And I keep that in mind as I
look forward to where we are now, also recognizing we did have the pandemic and that did have an
impact on all of the schools here in California. But to date, there have been two notices of concern
that have been issued to the charter and those issues have not yet been rectified,
which is why this item is before us today. So just to reiterate again, the notice of violation,
in my lens, provides opportunity for the formal process to begin so that we can, as a board,
hear more information and more of the specifics to support or refute really what those concerns
are. So again, just want to reemphasize an action on this particular item is not to choose to revoke
the charter, close the school, or anything along that line. It just opens the more formal process
for us to receive more information related to some of the concerns that have been brought up
so that we can make an informed decision moving forward.
Member Olken.
Thank you. And thank you, Vice President Glover-Woods, for reframing the purpose of
the notice of violation because as a new board member and the leader of a district-approved
charter, this is something that is not a common occurrence, so it's good to get the
reiteration of the point of it. I just wanted to comment on the
number two, the failed to meet or pursue any of the people outcomes identified in the charter
petition. In the time since this school opened, we've all, I think, had to pivot in one way or
another in terms of thinking about what the most important outcomes are for kids as they were
dealing with a worldwide crisis. And I think while academic outcomes are obviously our first
priority, I think they absolutely can't be our sole priority. And so I think it's important to
recognize the way in which the time period of the opening of this school
may have impacted certainly number two on this list and perhaps the others as well.
I am most interested in understanding the financial position of the school
in order to meet its obligations to its staff. And perhaps that's what this
notice of violation would allow us to dig further into. But I also was interested in hearing about
the revised budget based on only having 85 students because perhaps it already has been addressed.
If you want to, Ramirez, did you want to respond to that?
Yes, if I may. Thank you so much for the question. And yes, I would agree with President
Darling-Hammond in regards to the term fiscal mismanagement. I mean, when you look up fiscal
mismanagement, it really is a term that relates to gross abuse and negligence. And time is not in
any way engaged in that. Yes, there has been financial instability. And so what LACO has asked
in the conversation from us really is this issue of low enrollment. And so they said to us what
they thought the magic number was, 80 students. And so in the time that they issued the notice
on June 28th, that seemed to be what they believe the magic number. So like I shared with you in
my response, we currently have 72 fully registered families with another 16 in process right now that
brings us to 88. In addition to the other families that we have listed that have an interest that
we're continuing to pursue one month still prior to school opening. So again, they stated that
they believe that we didn't have the capacity or that the projections were unreachable. And then
these numbers that I'm sharing with you, that is just not the case. We are going to reach these
numbers. And after receiving this notice, we were instructed to start running numbers. Can you achieve
a budget on 80 students? We did it on 85 because as of right now, we even look at 88, but I did
it on 85. And on 85 students, time community schools is viable and we do meet the 3% reserve.
So what I would say is that first, again, number one, fiscal mismanagement, I just think is a
terrible mischaracterization of our school because we are so committed to our school and our community
and being transparent and making sure that we make decisions that really support our programs
and our staff and what we're attempting to do. So I would, again, argue that the three findings,
one, two, and three simply do not apply to us. And even so, we still have addressed all of these
issues to make sure that there are no concerns moving forward. So thank you again. And I'll
answer any other questions if you require more clarification.
Are there other questions?
I have a question for our CDE staff.
There are terms like fiscal mismanagement that would be understood, for example, as
corruption of some sort as opposed to instability and challenges. And I wonder whether when we make
the, when we are voting on the notice, whether it in fact comes with these characterizations.
I also wonder about the characterization of fail to pursue any of the pupil outcomes
as opposed to fail to meet. It seems frankly like overreach in the language.
So that is the reasons outlined in Ed code to issue a notice of violation. So I'm not
100% sure how we can change those in the resolution. So I welcome any input from
from SBE general counsel
on that in terms of the actual resolution language.
So again, Stephanie is correct. This is what the Ed code says. And if you will recall,
last winter, the board issued a notice of violation for the equal collegiate academy.
And one of the allegations was also fiscal mismanagement. And that has to do with
instability as Lego has laid out, the fact that they're buying on borrowing receivables,
that there is some concern that staff and STRS, there's not sufficient funding to pay
staff and STRS moving forward. And that is the long accepted definition of fiscal mismanagement.
And this is what is in Ed code. And I'd like to reiterate what
board member Glover Woods said. This is the first step in the process
at the ACCS. Should the board decide to issue the notice of violation,
the school will have a chance to prepare, respond, and there'll be a thorough hearing at ACCS
to go over whether the response adequately respond adequately, if they adequately have a plan
to respond to some of the concerns Lego has alleged. And that will be the place where the
ACCS can really dive into the merits of some of these issues. But this is the first step in
a formal process. And there are plenty of opportunities for them to respond moving forward.
Is that also the case, Judy, with respect to statements like failed to meet or pursue
any of the pupil outcomes, which makes it sound as though there's not even been an effort to
educate the students, which we have not heard any evidence of that.
Yes, you're correct, President Darling-Hammond. That is true, but it is an or. So again,
we're issuing a notice of violation, the school will have an opportunity to respond to all of
these allegations and their plan moving forward. The ACCS will deliberate on whether that plan
sounds real and then that may or may and then that will come back to the board in September.
I would say one thing with the timing, the pandemic is certainly cause a lot of instability in the
system. But the other thing to keep in mind is when the school closes mid-year, and I'm not saying
that that's something that's going to happen with this school. We certainly have no evidence of that,
but one of the reasons why these often come to you in the summer is because a mid-year closure
is often very difficult on the families, the students and the staff involved. So I think
that's partially, I think someone had a question about the timing and it's unfortunate and it's
unfortunate that the pandemic has caused enrollment problems for many schools. But again, that leads
to a lot of the fiscal problems that we are hearing from LACO here. Member Olken.
Thank you. Yeah, I just wanted to elevate the idea that one of the real issues that's plaguing
this school seems to be student enrollment and issuing a notice of violation would probably or
could potentially, try not to predict the future, could potentially exacerbate that.
And so in essence, there are students who are in the process of registration. And so I just want
to point out this could be a self-fulfilling prophecy. And I wonder in the public comment,
there weren't any students or families speaking up. And I wonder if that's
because in order to maintain a sense of stability in the school, the families don't know. I truly am
thinking through the lens of what I would do as a school leader and the types of calculations
I would be making. But it's striking both that we didn't hear from any students or families.
And then in my mind, I have this sense of perhaps why not. Is that a question?
And if so, who are you directing? Yeah. So the first part was just something to point out
about the impact of enrollment on when there's stability in a school, instability in a school.
And then the second, I guess, is a question for the director
if his community is aware of this potential that we're discussing today.
Thank you for the question and for the thoughtfulness of it. Yes, I think again,
in looking at number one in terms of issuing the notice, that is one of our concerns as well.
We have made a lot of progress. And LACO throughout the year always is commenting
on the progress that we make and our commitment, our work ethic. At one point in the last meeting,
in fact, that we had with LACO, LACO described me as extraordinary. So there is an acknowledgement
that we work very hard and that we're committed to the school. And so we're trying to do everything
in our power to give the families the confidence that they need to enroll in our school, given the
fact, too, that we are within a district that has been very challenging. And so we have all these
different factors that affect us and we've been combating them all year. So with that, yes,
there has been little information given to families to not give that concern that there
is this huge possibility of closure. We've been very strategic in how we've shared that
information and it's been more on as families have asked questions, we have provided if there
were any and have just been very minimal in sharing that information. Thank you. Any other
questions or comments? Seeing none, is there a motion?
I think the fact that we're not receiving a motion. Oh, there we go.
I don't know. They reflect some of the discomfort on the board. I don't know.
And I'm wondering whether there are steps that we can take to trigger the responses that are
needed from the school short of a notice of violation with the kind of language that this includes.
I don't know of any, President Carling-Hammond. I don't know if you wanted me to answer that,
but I don't know of any and I just want to say that this really is their opportunity to respond
in a way. They've offered a lot of new information here today that was not given to CDE or LACO prior
to writing of this item or posting of this item. So this is all new information that they are
sharing today and so the notice of violation would give both CDE and LACO an opportunity to
review it in a thoughtful way, which obviously we can't do it now. So I think this is the way
for the school to show how they are going to respond to the concerns.
Vice President Clover Woods?
I had a question. I had a question, Director Farland, to the point that you made.
Are you able or is it possible to review the new information that's been received with the
new enrollments and all of the new budget and various things that Director Ramirez has shared?
Is it possible to have that reviewed absent issuing a notice of violation or is a notice
of violation required in order to review the new information that has been presented since
the item was written?
I think this is a question to Stephanie Farland. Is that right?
I'm sorry. I thought she was asking. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I thought you were asking LACO.
I apologize. Well, we certainly and LACO can review information certainly at any time,
but if, for instance, we review it and it's not a cure or a remedy to all of the concerns,
then we certainly have to come back and do this process all over again
in order to move on to the next step. So we would have to repeat it.
Thank you.
Yeah, this is Judy. I'd like to add to what Stephanie said. So if the board chooses to not
issue a notice of violation now, certainly we can ask that LACO continue to work with the school.
Should LACO still have concerns after they review the new information the school has provided today,
then it's possible they would need to come back to the board for a notice of violation in September
and then that would mean that the revocation hearing would happen. In theory, if the board
decided to issue a notice of violation in September, then a revocation hearing would happen in November.
Member Escobedo, you had, oh, Member Glover-Woods, did you want to follow up on that before I take
the next question? No, please go to Member Escobedo and then you can come back to me if no one else
has their hand up. Thank you. Member Escobedo. Yeah, I was in line with Member Woods if we can
just table this. If we take no action, we could obviously hear this later and I just, for me,
I want to make sure this is an important decision because a notice of violation can lead to revocation
and, you know, that will be, something will be, I agree with Member Olken that that could actually
create a self-fulfilling prophecy as well. So I just want to make sure that before I make a decision,
I have all the facts and I'm still hung up with number two. I just don't feel like I'm comfortable
I'm comfortable in making this significant decision. It's more than just procedural.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez. I just want to kind of bring up what one of our members, I think it was
Ms. Olken, brought up. I'm concerned that we didn't hear from the community,
from the students of the school. I would have liked to have heard from the students who attend
Time Charter and to see how the school impacts them, maybe from the teachers. And
for me, that would have made an impact. But otherwise, since they didn't have anyone from
the community, then I feel like the investment is not fully there.
Yeah, I think we heard that they are not necessarily aware of this action.
Yeah, and that's what concerns me because I feel that one of the biggest things that I think that
school districts do is they really encompass the community. You know, we build bridges,
we build partnerships, and we invest in our communities. And I would like to have heard
from the teachers who are invested, the parents, and the students because this impacts them also.
And their voice is vital. And it's an awkward process because this is not the place where that
is set up to happen. At the point at which that would happen, it would be at a hearing
about the revocation, at which point it begins to feel like it's, you know, way down the road.
So we are, you know, again, it's a procedural challenge that we are facing.
Member Glover Woods, and then what member Lewis is also?
Go ahead, member Glover Woods, do you want to?
I do. I just want to say I definitely concur with the feeling of many of my fellow members on the
board. This is a very difficult, difficult decision. And I too would have wanted to hear
a bit more from those who are vested in the school, either in written correspondence or
during public comment today. And absent that, it's a little difficult. One thing that continues
to weigh on me is the fact that there have been two notices of concern that have already
been issued and apparently have not been resolved to the desire of the county office.
And that is why this is before us today. I definitely understand how issuing a notice of
violation can impact the registrations that are currently in place for the charter and that are
desperately needed for the charter. I'm just not sure that weighs or outweighs, if you will,
the implication of not issuing a notice of violation today and hoping that this time around,
the third time around, that the areas of concern would be resolved so that this is not before us
again later in the school year where we would need to take action on issuing a notice of violation.
And if we do and things are not resolved, moving forward with a revocation. So I just,
again, understand for myself just the quandary, if you will, in making this decision.
I do feel, however, that probably the best way to try to bring this to resolution and hopefully
resolution in benefit of the charter itself is to move forward with the notice of violation
so that we can get resolution to the concerns that have been brought forward.
And one last thing I will say, the language in Ed code is quite unfortunate that because it does,
I do believe, send a message, but I also understand that if that's the way the Ed
code is written, we have to adhere to that particular language as we move forward.
I saw a hand from Member Lewis.
President Darlin-Hammond, I apologize, but I do not have the icon at the bottom to raise my hand.
I don't know what happened. Sometimes it does seem to show up.
And I looked in the apps. I can't find it in the apps.
No worries. I apologize for that.
But I agree with everything that has been said by my fellow board members about how difficult this
is, especially hearing from Mr. Ramirez. And he's very heartfelt. He's very sincere
about all of the efforts that they are making to keep the school open and to provide the
opportunity for students. But I've been listening and I'm trying to think of, you know, what would
be a reason, a really valid reason not to move forward with issuing the notice of violation,
other than what I've heard about that it could impact the number of parents and students who
decide to go to the school. Well, it could also, if they have 200 names of students who have
expressed interest in being a part of the school and 72 that are committed with another 16 in
progress, it may also do the opposite. It may actually motivate those parents to know that,
hey, if we really want to be a part of this innovative school and we want to be a part of
keeping it open, then we have to move and act on our enrollment. And then there's no guarantee
if we don't move forward with this, that all of those parents will and students will step forward
and the enrollment will be at the magic number it needs to be to make the budget work and
the school can move forward. I too have concerns about the other two notices that were issued.
And then there wasn't an appropriate or an acceptable response to those. So I do believe
that this is the opportunity, you know, with the notice of violation for the school to just
continue to work as hard as they're working the staff to get the students and the parents on board
to be a part of the school. And which is I hope that that's what really that happens and that
they're able to move forward. And then in August, when the ACCS reviews things that everything is
in a good place and the school can move forward for the year. But I really think there's a benefit
to both to the school and to all those concerned to issue the notice and get the proof on the table
and all of the resources and things that are needed to make the school move forward.
So that's it. Appreciate that. I see another, I see Member Glover Woods raising her hand.
I'll just note that what I think all of the logic around getting the
answers to the questions clearly on the table is good logic. I think I heard Stephanie say that
that could be done in any event. Concerns here about whether there might be a mid-year closing.
I am continue to be troubled by the language of the notice, which I think is not accurate to the
work of the school around pursuing academic achievement and engaging in fiscal mismanagement.
So I will just leave that. Member Olken?
Thank you for calling me. But I think you had already said you were going to
go with Vice President Glover Woods next. Or was that a no? Sorry, I just don't want to jump.
No, go ahead. Yeah, Vice President Glover Woods, go ahead.
President Darling-Hammond, I can defer to Member Olken for her comment first.
Thank you. I just wanted to comment on the language one more time that you just mentioned,
President Darling-Hammond. Your question about whether it could be changed,
and the answer was it can't be, because those are the reasons in Ed code that we would issue
a notice of violation is troubling to me, because it's important to me. Because if
what we think is those words aren't the right ones, we can't change them because we don't have the
right to issue a notice of violation if those things aren't met. And so just your questioning
around the language and what it means is, I think, is important. I just wanted to reiterate
that. Thank you. All right. I think Member Glover Woods, the ball is in your court.
Okay. Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. I'd like to move forward with the motion
on this item, please, and I do move that we issue a notice of violation
and pursuant to the Ed code that is cited in the item. Thank you. And is there a second?
I second it. Thank you. Any further discussion of the item? Brooks will call a roll call vote.
Okay. Member Bonacca.
Aye. President Darling-Hammond.
Nay. Member Escobedo.
Nay. Vice President Glover Woods.
Yes. Member Lewis.
Yes. Member McQuillan.
Nay. Member Olken.
Nay. Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Yes. Member Petillo-Brownson.
Yes. Member Rodriguez.
I think she might have had to have left for her flight.
So the motion carries.
All right. Thank you all for a very intensive board meeting.
Executive Director Allen, do we have six aye votes? We need six aye votes for a motion to carry
pursuant to Ed code. No, we have five.
Motion fails. So then the board has taken no action. Unless someone wants to reconsider
the motion, that results in no action by the board. Thank you. All right. Then the board has
taken no action. Thank you for the very intense and deep board meeting. Thank you all for your
very determined participation. And I hereby adjourn our July 2022 State Board of Education
meeting at 1249 p.m. I look forward to seeing you in September.
Thanks, everybody.